Bye, bye, boo!
Go-bye, go-bye, go-bye!
Go-bye, go-bye!
Hello, everybody!
Welcome in!
Howdy, dody!
Welcome, do I go tag you!
I'm glad you like Nimi's concert!
Uh...
She's here.
I'm always here.
It's a Minto clock!
On the hour!
Or five past.
Whatever.
You were amazing!
Thank you!
It was so fun!
For those who don't know, Nimi Nightmare had her one-year
anniversary concert, 3D concert, yesterday, last night.
And I was a special guest.
I got to sing with Nimi and Phoebe.
So...
Yay!
Nimi just talked about how she was impressed with your
dramatic katana skills.
You know...
I...
I was watching a clip someone that...
Clipped of it.
Oh, he's like, John, we did Visconti yesterday.
You all looked so great.
Thank you, Kamu!
I was watching a clip of it and I was like...
I don't know what...
I thought I thought maybe I thought maybe um that the the
music would be loud enough that you wouldn't hear us
laughing here I am I'm like you have to follow the order how
hard was quoting Star Wars instead of Raiden oh man well
that's what Nimi wanted she wanted she wanted the Star Wars
quote so I was like okay whatever you want girlie girlie
papa got you it's your show show is incredible but you need
to work on your sword skills darth minke what are you
talking about i'm the one who beat i had the sword at the
end what are you talking about i i knocked nimmy sword out
of her hand but i remember the way you guys broke character
was so funny i remember uh afterwards and everything nimmy
was just like Wow, that was so good.
I didn't expect you to get so into it.
Yeah, it's cool.
Was that even her sword?
I don't know whose swords those were.
They were just on the ground.
Nimmy cheated.
No force powers.
No, she just used her resources.
But yeah, it was so much fun.
Check it out.
Watch the concert.
If you haven't yet, it's so fun.
Can't believe Phantom everything died.
No, I just, I took a nap.
I didn't die.
So we're doing a Star Wars watch along so you can understand
the references, yeah?
I feel like at this point I've done so many Star Wars things
I need to watch the movies.
Right?
I go on Star Wars rides.
I talk about Star Wars things.
I should do a watch-along maybe, huh?
You mean you have it?
As a sword instructor, you unironically had some pretty good
flow?
You think so?
Wait.
Just need to work on defense against BS nature wizard
powers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was my birthday earlier this week, but I've been so busy
with her work, I haven't had time to get you live.
Liquid Toast!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
In release order, please.
Who do you... What do you take me for?
Of course in release order.
I don't do timeline order ever.
I do release order.
Almost always.
It's funny because I also...
Like, you know, because...
I...
watch a lot of it's typically like Disney theme park
specifically news right because I'm a theme park enthusiast
and so I'll get like a lot of things on Disney theme parks
in my timeline but occasionally I'll get like other just
like Disney random stuff right and I saw someone recently
showing off Star Wars jewelry um You'd like the Star Wars
movie, Indiana Jones is in them.
What?
Uh...
David Hasselhoff!
No.
What's his name?
Don't tell me.
How's that age, no?
I don't remember.
Harrison Bord!
Who's Dave?
I only know David Hasselhoff from Spuddy.
SpongeBob.
What did that guy do?
Who is that guy?
Baywatch.
Prince of Denmark.
Thank you.
Bioshock is one of the series that I always have to watch.
It's been a great playthrough so far.
Watch out for splicers.
Thank you.
Knight Rider.
Wait, I don't know that one.
I know Baywatch.
That's where they are in the swimsuits and running slowly,
slow motion on the beach.
Looking so sexy.
It's old all.
But, um, yeah, I was watching somebody explain, like, the
jewelry and just kind of, like, showing it off.
And they were mostly complaining about it.
They were like, it's so ugly.
But they were, like, uh...
there were oh oh my gosh I keep wanting to say David
Hasselhoff no Harrison Ford he is Han Solo and he I guess
there were like rings that were just like okay this is a
line from from from Star Wars right where she's just like I
love you and he says I know is that supposed to then they
made rings out of that also i learned there's jewelry of han
solo like getting fossilized when does that happen but is
that supposed to be romantic i'm so confused spoilers oh i
have to watch yeah but they made they made jewelry out of it
and it's like his agonized face in the jewelry he's like
getting fossilized and you can wear it around your neck as a
necklace imagining an alternate universe where Hasselhoff
and Harrison Ford switch I think it's very funny that
Harrison Ford really loves being Indiana Jones and really
does not like being Han Solo at least that's how it appears
right
a nice carbonite bath yeah that's what the necklace was
called not carbonite bath but it was like it was like get
carbonated i don't know i don't it was something about
carbonite more bioshock excited yeah we're in arcadia we're
in arcadia today get carbonated
Carbonara Bath Sounds yummy Carbonara I didn't eat dinner
But I wasn't really hungry But I have dinner If I get hungry
So we might have a brief intermission snack break In the
middle of today's stream Just to let you guys know Delicious
Disney making products out of a tragic moment.
Classic Disney.
Hi, Minto.
Hello!
Welcome back, JR.
Thank you!
Yeah, so, um...
Why did I start talking about the Han Solo of everything?
I don't remember.
I ordered my pizza 75 minutes ago and I am still peaceful.
That is calls for a refund, I think.
75.
Well, it is a Saturday night.
I don't know.
Oh, the Nimmy Sword fight!
That's right.
Wouldn't be shocked if someone said there was actually Han
Solo's soda.
So...
Oh.
No.
Carbonite.
What's your favorite plasmid?
I love the one that lets you send out bees.
Ouch.
I don't know.
I don't have the bees.
I don't have the bees yet.
But someone told me about the bees last time.
I do not have the bees yet.
Cue, cue, cue, cue, cue, cue, cue, cue, cue, cue.
Woo, Sunday night.
Um.
Yeah, mind control big daddy.
That was fun.
My favorite, maybe, is, I don't know.
I don't know.
The electricity is so versatile.
I love it.
I can do anything with it.
But I'm sure there's many more as well.
Um, there was one thing else I wanted to say.
I don't remember.
Oh!
I want to talk about Portal 2.
Guys, I think I hate Wheatley.
I think I hate him the mostest.
He makes me so uncomfortable.
puzzles and I don't like it.
Crazy I haven't seen Star Wars, considering you voiced R2D2.
He is not a Himbo.
Himbo's are jolly.
This guy has so many self-esteem issues.
Which is not, you know, that's not, well, that's not like a
jab at him, but like, Himbo's are just supposed to be like,
yeah, I'm stupid.
But if you call Wheatley a moron, he gets so sad and upset,
which I guess is a normal reaction.
But what I'm saying is, is he, I don't like that I do a
puzzle, and he gets the shivers.
Freaks me out a little bit.
I'm on a puzzle.
That Wheatley guy, what a weirdo.
Thank goodness there's nobody like him here.
Are you getting off on me?
doing puzzles.
Was Glados?
But I'm not done with the game yet.
I'm not done with the game yet.
I'm stuck on a puzzle.
I was trying to figure it out.
But it was like 1 a.m.
yesterday.
And I was like, I think I'm tired.
I think I need to go to bed.
Maybe she was better at hiding it.
I like when she insults me.
a chapter 8.
I think I'm like almost done with chapter 8 though.
I think I'm a few puzzles until I finish chapter 8.
And then chapter 9.
We beat the game.
I'm gonna try and record more tonight.
Probably.
If I'm not too tired after Bioshock.
I think.
puzzle this last part I think I redeemed myself because in
part 6 I was it was terrible it was really bad but part 7 I
had major brain blast moments I I sped through every puzzle
they gave me except this last one it was awesome Nimi
Nightman!
Thank you for the raise!
Hi naplings!
Come back a lot!
We were just talking about the concert.
We were.
I hope you guys liked our epic sword battle.
And me being put to sleep by Nimi's awesome powers.
And...
All today?
Actually, all today though, I've just been going Kawaii
Kawaii Kawaii Kawaii Kawaii You did so good jumping on that
trampoline?
The trampoline was so fun.
I loved that part.
It was cinema.
Kawaii Kawaii Kawaiii Kawaii
I'm glad people appreciated my camera work.
Yeah.
Thank you so much for the free time.
We are just about to play Bioshock.
This is my first time ever playing Bioshock.
No spoilers, please, on plot and everything.
Well, thank you so much.
Thank you guys for all the good.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
We can always count on your camera, boss.
I give the people what they wisheth.
I giveeth.
I was with you on Team Winter, but after you swap sides, I
now feel betrayed.
You know what, actually, though?
I actually like Spring a lot, though.
I had to...
It was script.
It was scripted.
I'm sorry.
Actually, I can't wait.
for spring for real.
I can't wait for the warm weather.
The only thing I can't wait for is my allergies.
It was scripted!
I know, I'm so sorry.
It's just been so cold.
It's been so cold that I feel like I can never be warm.
You know, when you get that kind of level of cold, where
you're like, my, I will never feel warmth again.
That's how I feel right now.
I was going to say Mint Phantom well-renowned for her joy at
being cold.
Yeah, my ectoplasm is solid.
Enough snarl.
No!
Snarl, snarl.
We need more snarl.
Indeed.
I miss oblivion.
Wow, 22 months.
Thank you!
I got hit so hard when you three sang Pop Star.
I feel like it was decades since I...
listen to that song.
Yeah!
I wanna be a pop song.
Give me a mark.
What?
Cookies and cream.
Have nice, delicious Oreo filling.
I
wanna be a pop tart.
What?
Flavor.
Cookies and cream.
Have nice, delicious Oreo filling.
be a pop tart put me in the toaster and i'll pop out all
nice and hot for you brown sugar wow berry smore smore smore
we need more smore cherry i don't think i've ever had a
cherry pop tart brown sugar cinnamon advance happy valentine
mint thank you johnny I think Valentine's was last week.
Very super advanced.
The most advanced.
One whole year in advance.
Chokomito.
Ice, ice, ice, ice.
All right.
I'll stop procrastinating now.
Will you guys help me?
Okay.
After I'm done with Bioshock.
Ah.
Okay, I want your help with picking out a DIY craft.
Okay, so I have the tabs open.
I want to get something.
I hope it will come in time for Japan.
Because I want to get ones for Vicky and Phoebe too.
So if you guys will help me pick some stuff out.
And it's like this, it's like, okay, it's like...
They have a couple different things, and I kind of want to
get a couple things.
They're like, you can make a coaster, like for your mug, and
you can make a rug, and you can even make a bag!
Wait, what are they called?
Hold on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It just says a coaster kit.
But they're like very, they're like mossy-themed, right?
And they look so cute.
Very Phoebe core, actually.
and fries.
I got extra fries.
Yeah!
Someone in your chat needs to hear this.
Tomato, Celsius...
What is it?
I'm not reading this.
I feel like I'm summoning something.
What does that mean?
What does it mean?
I learned what Celsius is literally like this past weekend.
Isn't it?
Activation.
code.
Sleeper agent activated.
It's an energy drink, no?
It's an energy drink.
I learned about it.
Wait, what?
Like a temperature system?
No, no, no.
Celsius...
Wait, are they talking about Celsius's drink?
Or Celsius degrees?
Oh, wait.
I didn't even think about it.
I learned about the Celsius energy drink.
I know what I know what Celsius is.
The unit?
I'm not that stupid.
I know what Celsius is.
Actually, I use Celsius.
I know, right?
I'm like one of those types of ghosts.
I'm like, yeah, guys, all my...
Everything is in Celsius.
Like, a real person.
Everyone who's not American is proud of me, right?
She's a simple ghost.
She shoots and hacks.
Be kind.
All right, let's load.
We forgot how many.
Baby's first piano.
Arcadia.
All right, baby.
Me on the piano.
People said that Arcadia is cool.
I'm excited.
Oh.
Oh yeah, sorry about Moira and Patrick.
Sorry.
Waits and then he pulls the string.
I like Atlas's voice actor.
We'll find the bastard.
We'll find him and we'll tear.
Oh, Randru.
I came to this place to build the impossible.
You came to rob what you could never build.
A hum, gaping at the gates of Rome.
Even the air you breathe, sponged from my account.
Well, breathe deep.
So later you might remember the taste.
You get to the Bathespier in the Roland Hills.
That'll take you straight to the devil himself.
And then, all deaths will be...
Be paid in full.
Go to the metro station.
Alright, let's see what I've got going on here.
This is my hypnosis.
It's so icky.
Alright.
We'll keep this up.
And yes?
Kerosene?
What's that for?
Yes, I will be safe, scumming.
Uh, again.
Um, but I'm feeling more confident since it hasn't been so
long since I last played, so.
Oh, it's a thingy.
Is it broken?
Oh, no.
It's just...
The vitamin chamber.
Empty hypo?
Where the hell are these for?
Oh.
Oh, it's not one anymore.
Ooh.
Let's...
There we go.
Whoa!
How...
How'd they get so much greenery?
Tea garden!
I think it's a cemetery.
No?
Woo!
Ooh!
The Great Chain.
I know this looks like a...
Is this T?
I'm going around.
How many, uh, let's see.
We have two little sisters in this level.
Shell casing.
And kerosene?
What's going on here, huh?
What's going on here?
She was buried.
She's going to haunt me, I think, maybe.
Eat it and find out.
Liquid nitrogen!
I'm getting a lot of random rubber holes.
Wait, why am I getting so much random stuff all of a sudden?
What am I going to be building?
Liquid!
Beautiful.
Sorry.
It begins.
Alright, so you can suck the gas out of cars.
I guess we could try and do that.
I can't go in.
Hello!
Tea's tea garden.
This is very nice.
Ooh!
this is like really nice kerosene what's up with all this
stuff another camera a film I feel like dinosaurs are gonna
see ghosts seems like some poor blighters have started
seeing ghosts ghosts ghosts Ryan tells me it's a side effect
to this plasmid business one poor shot's getting passed on
to another through genetics army oh leaks lunatics rebellion
and now bleeding ghosts ain't life in rancher grand are you
guys seeing ghosts I see a ghost too I think you might you
okay you alright see what was that did that was that a
splacer Is that what that said?
Huh.
I think the subtitle's spoiled.
Why?
Thank you so much for the fun.
Thank you.
My camera.
Oh, man.
But we killed that guy that wanted all the stuff.
What?
Whoop.
Christ, is somebody there?
No.
Nobody's here.
He sounds so normal though.
He sounds so coherent.
Hey, can you help me man?
No.
Oh, oh, ghost!
What are you waiting for, Sydney?
It's beautiful.
Oh, Jesus God, somebody help!
Oh, I'm seeing ghosts!
Oh my god.
Alright, let's do this.
Let's uh...
Yeah.
All right.
I think the reason I prefer save scumming over just being,
just coming out of the pods or whatever that one was, is
because at least if I save scum, I get to keep all of my
items.
You know what I mean?
I get to keep my items and I get to try again.
I'd rather do that than like lose stuff.
What was it?
Six.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Oh.
Hey, can you help me, man?
Can you help me out?
What the hell?
Where'd he go?
Hello?
Oh, Jesus God, somebody help!
Okay.
Hello?
Oh.
Who is yelling?
I can't see anything.
I feel like I need better prescription.
Oh, Jesus, guys.
Come on, somebody.
Okay, I give it.
Please, I'm literally...
I'm total visioned right now.
Okay, we're going back to this, and then we're going back to
this.
Okay.
It's so crunchy.
Anyway.
Hey, can you help me, man?
Can you help me?
Oh, dang it, you jerks!
I got him.
Houdini splicer!
Wait, don't I get a new thing?
Oh, increased damage.
Houdini splicers are vulnerable to...
Oh, it's the machine, machine.
Wait, um, wait, uh...
Uh, B?
No.
this one.
Okay, now I'm scared.
Now I'm scared.
Okay, okay, okay, hold on.
I'm scared.
They're scary.
This guy's all over the place.
Hello?
You need my help?
You want me?
You want to talk?
Or something?
I don't want to go in here because I'll use my electricity.
I know it and I'll get zappy zapped so.
I could go...
Where's my values?
Okay, let's try it this way.
Um...
Okay.
Wait, what's down here?
though.
I don't want to just follow him blindly, like an idiot.
Check out all the stuff around here.
Dollars.
I didn't
get hurt from that, did I?
Okay, I guess we go back upstairs.
They've got their own little cult in here.
I'm good.
Okay, cool.
Hey!
Where are you?
Maybe, uh...
Um,
wait, how do I switch again?
There we go.
His plant!
Fight with fire!
But he's also fire plant!
But I fight with fire!
I already took a picture of him.
Let's take a picture of him dead.
score too low yeah I already took a bit chlorophyll solution
interesting
nice what is this oh today Arcadia was closed off to all but
paying customers the man hires me to build a forest at the
bottom of the ocean and then turns a walk Fight fire with
fire.
Riot asked, should a farmer not be able to sell his food?
Is a potter not entitled to a profit from his pots?
I started to argue with a man.
Langford, I don't think we met her yet.
I remember who signed my checks.
Only thing worse than a hypocrite is an unemployed one.
Rubber hose.
What am I making?
Oh, uh, well actually, I guess that worked.
But it gets get him spliced and diced.
I don't think I need to switch out anything.
I don't think I honestly really had anything to switch.
Oh, the security.
Nah, it's okay, I think we're good for now.
No, no, no.
Very very interesting.
Everything in here.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh,
another automatic hack.
No, I like the hack.
I do the hacking.
I do the cooking.
It's a VTuber not entitled to her super chest.
Wait, what's it here?
Crawl space door.
Why is it bloody?
We go in.
Oh.
Cigarettes?
Ah!
Oh, it's...
It's...
It's just crying.
Eh.
Coffee.
Oh, shoot.
I'm just gonna...
What?
It doesn't think it's...
Thank you so much for the pink!
Beyond the Sea has been one of my favorite songs for a
while.
It was wonderful to hear you sing it with Sava.
Thank you!
Was that me?
Pretty good.
There's something really funny about shooting him and then
like...
Get on fire over there!
Okay, anyway.
Let's take that.
Searched.
Yeah, everything in here I didn't really need, did I?
Well, cool.
Now I know.
Why are they like that?
Why are they so sniffly?
Allergies?
Nice shot.
Thank you.
Oh, it scared me.
Glue!
Oh, this guy didn't even have a thuggish splicer.
You know, I realized I forgot to, like, look over here,
actually.
I was too afraid.
Wait, what is this?
Can I set this on fire?
Cigarettes?
Or afraid?
Well, I did, but it didn't do anything.
I definitely need to do something.
Yes, cent.
It's not that I'm a pyromaniac, it's just that it's plant.
Weak to fire.
I play Pokemon.
I did give me the grenade launcher though, so I guess we'll
try that.
Oh, it went a waste.
Oh.
Go back to my pistol.
Oh, I thought that was another.
Okay, so there was a door over here.
Always quick to violence.
We'll come back to that.
There was another door anyway that I didn't go through.
Oh, oh!
They're all running everywhere.
Hello?
It's a sh-sh-sh- Hello?
Where'd they go?
I like the music, though.
Oh,
somebody's up there, for sure.
Don't mind me!
Oh.
They're, like, running around so fast.
Come on.
Oh!
I shot the...
No, don't reload.
Actually, I need to reload.
Again.
Oh, I should be taking pictures of these guys.
I forget.
I wish my camera had zoomed though, you know.
So chill here.
Oh.
There's a lot of stuff going on in there.
Okay.
What was that?
Oh, I thought someone was coming up behind me.
You're still on fire.
Where are you going?
Oh my god.
I feel like I'm in like a Western shootout, you know?
Are they dead?
No.
Sorry,
I didn't get to see her super child!
Thank you!
Happy birthday!
Root and toot and minto shooting.
Yeah.
Is
it a person?
Or is it a turret?
That seems like a turret.
Oh, it got me good, though.
Alright.
Run!
I didn't realize there were three of them.
Alright, it's like about here.
Ah!
Yes!
We're hacking?
My favorite part of the game!
Yeah, baby!
Yeah, we're hacking!
Oh yeah!
Uh...
There we go!
She's a plumber for real!
Yeah, Bima...
Don't get me though.
I'm out of bullets.
Oh, yikes.
We have fun here, guys.
We have fun here.
We sure do.
The Circus of Value.
What is it?
Two out of nine?
We'll get another one.
Liquid Nitrogen.
For the Chemical Thrower.
Particularly effective against targets vulnerable to cold
and will be will freeze creatures if spun or continue
spontaneously applied napalm wait do i have a chemical
thrower what's in my chemical throw no
i don't know not yet
Thought I heard something walking.
There's another crawl space.
I like to save before these because all hell breaks loose
when you go in through them apparently.
Can I shut it?
Ah!
what is that wait why is it oh it's probably cuz it's that
anyway no wait is this all pool no this is a cat I'm losing
blood I'm not a woman am I Honey!
Give me some meds!
Come on!
You think it's rotten potatoes?
That's cute.
Real cute.
Okay, let's hack this.
Sorry, I'm gonna save again because these are harder.
I think it's fertilizer.
Not like kitty poo.
Okay.
Holy cow!
I'm glad I just saved.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh,
I gotta go fast, I gotta go fast, I gotta go...
Ah!
I've already lost it.
This is why we do what we do.
Will you play Bioshock 2 at some point?
I'd like to?
Is it just three games?
Bioshock 1, 2, and Infinite?
Oh, I didn't even see the bandages there.
Pretty nice.
oh my gosh i'm oh i'm not getting like anything that i need
ah oh dang it oh my gosh this one's really tough okay hold
on yes with dlc but yes ah okay okay oh infinite is a
different universe oh universe different universe i could
also use the auto hack but I keep trying.
I just need the one stinking thing that I need!
Ah!
No, please!
Oh,
that's a spoiler.
How was it a spoiler?
Oh, actually, don't answer that.
Oh wait, uh, you.
And then, uh, you.
And then, uh...
You.
Yes.
Ah, yes, yes, yes.
Uh, shoot, shoot, shoot.
No, no, no.
Ah!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We were so close.
Yes, yes, yes, no, no, no!
Okay, okay.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, okay, okay.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
And then, uh, you.
Uh, but no.
Uh, yes, but no.
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
You, you, you, you, you.
There we go.
And what?
This is so unlucky!
These, this, that was the unluckiest poll ever.
Oh my god!
Rigged!
Sorry, I'm gonna... I'm gonna...
Now I'm like stubborn about it.
Now I want to do it, you know?
Okay, uh...
Oh, I...
I already lost as soon as I...
Sorry, everybody.
Something weird's happening during my night shifts.
My car windows unfroze itself, but all my other cars remain
frozen.
The next night, The fire extinguisher case suddenly opened
by itself?
And a little poltergeist activity.
Okay, okay, okay, this sucks.
Everything, okay, fine.
Fine, I'll use the auto-hack.
Fine!
I'll use the auto-hack.
I give up.
This one's so hard.
One of the characters in Bioshock Infinite had quite the
effect on the indie animation.
you're talking about.
I, like, know the designs for, like, the character designs
for Bioshock games.
Don't give up.
You can hack it.
You guys believe in me!
Okay.
I won't give up because you won't give up.
You don't give up on me.
I won't give up.
Oh, shoot.
You guys didn't give up on me!
You guys didn't give up on me and so I didn't give up!
Yeah!
Christ!
You think that I'm dumb?
Okay, I got some stuff.
Oh, honey!
Give me some meds now!
This guy is so funny.
Don't face me, will you?
Huh?
That's not him.
Oh, there he goes.
God damn it, I'm bleeding!
I'm charging by the minute, you nothing!
Blood!
Where is he?
I'm losing blood!
Is he okay?
I think he's losing blood, you guys!
That won't stop!
He even run like a little girl!
Oh, I think he died!
I said I didn't have to do anything.
Minto wins by doing nothing.
Have you ever tried to not be the most amazing ghost that
can do anything?
I don't know.
It ain't easy being cheesy.
Where's your weapons?
No, no work.
Maybe if I... well, hold on.
Let's go around this way first.
Oh wait.
Where is she going?
Oh, I think she's angry at that thing for attacking her.
Oh, she was stupid.
She got angry.
She didn't aggro on me.
She aggroed on the...
On this guy.
Good job.
Oh, value.
Come in.
Three.
All right.
What is in here, though?
Okay.
Is this a trap?
Can I not search?
I can't search it.
Is it too high up?
Do I hit the telekinesis?
Have you ever played Dishonored?
I have not!
I have not played it before.
The game physics are so funny.
Okay.
all right then oh i didn't hack this guy every i thought i
heard someone walking maybe i do i can't though maybe i
don't um i like hacking because we get stuff for it you know
We get even everything.
And also, hack fun.
Hacking fun.
I like the ones where it's a little less stressful.
Yeah.
But also, it's nice to make things cheaper, right?
So this room is dangerous.
Did he die?
He ran over here.
But what did he run into?
Actually, I have no idea.
He ran into another wire.
Yeah, but like...
Where?
I'm actually very confused.
Oh, they disappear when hit!
Oh, I see.
Bugish Spicer is vulnerable to antipersonnel.
Oh, I have that.
Okay, cool.
You think I can get over here?
Oh!
Oh no, I cannot.
Oh, but I want to...
Can I...
Can I be solid snake?
I want to get over there.
Telekinesis, you're a genius.
Oh.
Ah!
Okay.
Problem solved.
Don't grab the thing that's electrified.
We're fine, everything's fine.
Alright, um, let's go.
Let's keep going.
Where am I going?
Rapture!
Oh, to the Metro!
That's right, that's our goal.
Oh, we're at the Metro.
I thought those were pumpkins.
This is very lived-in.
Overgrowth?
Why?
I- I thought the metro would be like a subway, no?
Arcadia Glens.
What was that?
Lots of stuff in here.
Oh!
Thank you.
Alrighty.
Circus of values.
What is this for?
Nothing.
Oh, oh, a circle.
She adores the summertime.
Someone shot fire at her and it wasn't me!
That doesn't seem good.
wait is this the other side of the area that i was in before
i think so so we can just ignore that maybe arcadia glens i
saw something flashing over there
okay oh there's some eve over there too wait there's a lot
of stuff going on around here okay who shot at her was it a
rocket maybe yeah who's Are you casting fireballs?
Fireball.
Let your shins abound.
Maybe I should be on fire.
There's nothing over here.
I thought that said pocky.
It's gonna be like somebody in raptures.
A little weeaboo.
I hear him still.
Invent items?
What?
We're mining and crafting now?
No way.
Oh, oh, oh, no, no, no.
What the heck is happening?
This is a bizarre one.
Oh, it actually...
Oh, shoot.
You.
And then... you.
What is it doing that?
Wish I could whistle like that guy.
Wait, oh, oh, uh, uh, what should I whistle?
Oh!
We're mining and we're crafting.
Huh?
Inventable item.
Four rubber hose.
4 battery Oh I don't have the tube But also Being able to
buy armor piercing auto rounds That's kind of awesome What
Exploding book Oh And anti-personnel Pistol rounds Oh
But which is i wonder which would be better the pistol or
the or the machine gun ones you better get some more money
buddy money i don't think this is money i think i like my
pistol more the machine the machine gun right now it has too
much recoil you know there's also the exploding book this is
this powerful buckshot explodes on contact with the target
dealing extra damage to all targets these bullets are
specifically designed to neutralize non-armored targets like
splicers well I guess these ones are great for big daddy's
though aren't they well we will hold off for now we can
always come back He sounds like right next to me.
What if he's below?
He's right below me?
Wait, is he below me?
Did I just save?
Wait, I can't remember.
Sorry.
Yeah, we'll revisit once we have some stuff.
Actually, wait, is he down there?
There's somebody.
There is this though.
Wait, so I can go in here.
But I also can't go in here.
Um...
Oh, come on!
Shouldn't that have hit?
There we go.
Oh, there's something up top too.
I don't think he's in here.
Oh.
I'll take that for sure.
Thank you.
Anything else?
No?
Ugh, ugh.
I don't like the water effect at all.
There's more stuff here!
How do I get rid of it?
My fire didn't work before.
Telekinesis!
On it?
Later on.
Okay, okay.
Oh.
Thanks.
I'm trying to like have my stuff ready that I want to use.
Alright.
I'm like...
Oh, I'm supposed to go this way.
But I want to explore the upper area first.
There's a lot to explore in this one.
The Circus of Value.
The audio glitches get me, like, really bad.
Oh, Big Daddy.
Tree Farm.
Oh, he's, like, right there.
What's going on?
Hello?
Yeah!
Oh.
Okay.
Oh,
I should take a picture.
You're right.
That would have been awesome.
Oh, he would have been mid-action.
It probably would have been like an A.
It would have not been.
Dang.
It would have been so good.
That was so cool!
Good job, Big Daddy!
Mr. Bubbles, you did such a great job!
Awesome!
Oh, it's a vita chamber.
Oh, I did not mean to drink that coffee.
Whatever.
Yeah, don't come over here.
Don't do that.
Don't come over here.
Yeah.
We take those, we take those, we take those, yeah, yeah,
yeah, when it has a nice little...
Um, hello?
Any more?
Oh, thank you.
Coffee for Eve.
It's coffee's... wait.
Easy to farm big daddy's is to mind control one, provoke a
fight with another, then they weaken each other.
Yeah, that's what I did last time, it was awesome.
I have 340 Adam Is there anything new here?
Oh, winter Blast Electro Bolt 2 Stuns longer Cycle Oh my
gosh, wait, there's so many more Vending expert Reduces
pricing in vending machines Oh my gosh, wait, okay, there's
so much more Okay, hold on Plasmid slot Physical tonic slot
Oh, oh, oh, oh Oh, those are good.
Those are good.
Eve Upgrade.
Sonic Boom.
Hurls creatures and objects back with a blast of force.
Creates a decoy that draws attacks away from you.
Winter Blast.
Freeze your foes in place.
Shatter them into a thousand pieces.
Wait, that's kind of awesome.
Fusro da!
Electro Bolt 2 Electric Boogaloo Literally
The slot is super useful Launches splicers into the air And
hurts them badly on the way down The music that plays during
the Help Me Houdini's splicer encounter Is the same exact
music from the Shining's infamous bathtub scene That's scary
You take less damage from fire and inflict more damage when
you Use fire.
That's pretty good.
Eve saver.
Plasmids use less Eve.
Wait, that's kind of huge too.
Extra nutrition.
You gain a little extra health from snacks and bandages.
Machine buster increases damage you deal to cameras, bots,
and turrets.
Yeah, but I like to hack them.
Security X support reduces difficulty when hacking turrets,
bots, and cameras.
I like the... I like the...
The...
The challenge.
Speedy Hacker.
I don't know.
I feel like we should get the slots for things.
Oh.
How do I see my slots?
Wait.
How do I?
I thought it was tab.
Wait.
Shift.
Just kidding.
No.
Not shift.
Wait.
How do I see my slots?
The thrill of the tubes.
Oh, we're gonna get two more.
How exciting.
Should be a gene bank nearby, was there?
Over here.
Maybe.
Wait, am I going the right way?
Yes.
Oh!
Loser?
Can I go this way, though?
Oh, he's, like, right in front of it.
Okay.
Yes, please move.
Please move.
There's a lady right behind that door.
Okay, let's see what we got.
I don't think I had that many engineering ones at the
moment.
was literally just these two that i have um i think i wish i
could tell this one static no we had the static discharge
that was another thing that we had for um for the combat
physical we have quite a few if i remember correctly
scrounger when searching you can search again to get
different loot since it's kind of fun.
Hackers delight.
That's the one we have right now.
And then this one first aid kit gives you slightly more
health.
Keep that one obviously.
Combat and physical are nice.
This is our first time being able to buy stuff.
So,
like buy more slots even, you know?
I wish it would tell you what kind of upgrade it is though.
You know what I mean?
Like, is it a physical or engineering?
This one obviously seems like a plasmid shot or slot thing.
This one seems really cool.
The winter blast?
Is it any good?
yeah you know what you mean we know what i mean are you
harvesting no we're saving the little sisters oh but you get
no loot from it it's good you lose the loot easy kill but no
loot ah i see okay that's good to know
okay okay okay Three hit, if you recall.
Okay, I'll try to remember that.
Freeze the entire ocean.
Yeah, I'll just gather all the Eve, and then I'll just go
into the ocean and freeze everything and then leave.
Like, some of these seem good.
I just don't know what to get.
Um...
Eve saver.
Oh yeah, Eve saver, right?
Yeah, that one's huge.
We will buy that one, at least.
Physical tonic.
Okay, then I will also...
Plasmids.
Wait, hold on.
I will get another physical tonic upgrade.
So I want all three of those.
I've plasmid, or...
Yeah, okay, here we go.
Because I think...
You saving Eve...
As much as I use it, it'll be good.
Mage build.
Right.
And then...
It's top.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, combat.
I could get another pl...
Okay, I'm going to get the winter blast in the meantime.
And I can always switch.
it out right you know we can always switch it out with
something i feel like i don't use telekinesis so often in
battle i only use it when i need it you know what i mean for
like items and things um because i don't think i'm i i often
feel like i'm grabbing the wrong thing i'm like grabbing the
wrong stuff as you can see just make sure to sing let it go
as you're
I will, obviously, I'm not getting rid of telekinesis, but I
want to keep hypnotized Big Daddy because I think it's like
great to have when the stars align and there's two guys just
hanging out around each other.
Yeah, telekinesis is situational, I agree.
So we'll just do this right now.
Freeze your enemies.
Shatter them into a thousand pieces.
Evolve today.
Why did they invite, or invite, uh, invent this.
I think that's all I'll do for now.
I feel like maybe I need, like, a health upgrade.
Oh, wait, though.
I would need a slot for this, wouldn't I?
The slots are so annoying.
Why can't it just be a permanent upgrade?
Hmm.
Oh, they don't take a...
Oh, health and eve upgrades don't take up slots oh oh so
they don't
do you think if i do a health upgrade and eve upgrade i mean
i feel like we're getting i will need to upgrade eventually
no as the as the enemies get stronger so
yeah i think i should do them
They're safe choices.
I agree.
All right, we'll do that then.
Your maximum health has been increased, allowing you to take
more hits without being sent to a res- Res- Res-
Resurrection!
I'll keep wanting to say resuscitation.
Eve.
You can now carry more Eve in your body, allowing you to use
more plasmids before having to reload with an Eve hypo.
Okay, cool.
Whoa!
Whoa, that's freaky!
Alright, I'm gonna save now too, since we did a bunch of
stuff.
That looks a little painful.
Waterfall Grottoes.
That guy's just carrying a grenade launcher right there.
They laugh you out of town.
Oh.
I'm supposed to be going the other way.
but that's fine what is this there has been tremendous
pressure to regulate this plasmid business there have been
side effects blindness insanity death but what use is our
ideology if it is not the market does not respond like an
infinite freaking at the first sign of displeasure the
market is patient and we
It was everything that was holding that guy together.
I was completely holding that guy together.
Uh-oh.
Uh, shoot.
Oh, wait.
I did the wrong thing.
Oh, my gosh.
Uh, holy that was close.
This is still winnable.
That was so close.
Holy cow.
Alright, now we can make some more rounds and stuff.
I'll hold off for now though.
Oh, I think I searched that guy already.
Oh, oh, are you coming in here?
No.
You were just taking a little peek?
I get it.
Alright.
Is it her?
Oh, that's awkward.
I don't know who should.
It sounds like a turret.
Oh, shatter them before they thawed.
Oh, oh, geez.
Wait, who is shooting at me anyway?
Oh.
I can't see anything!
I think there were two.
Two turrets.
Oh.
Well that didn't go nearly as planned.
In fact that was really quite terrible.
Don't come over to me.
Why are you literally looking at me?
Don't look at me.
Okay, anyway.
That was really terrible.
I will reload.
Actually...
So she didn't...
She didn't break.
Wouldn't dear welcome back, thank you!
She did not break.
I don't want him walking in here, you know.
You gotta be quicker?
Really?
No!
Stop tricking me.
Really?
There we go.
She's lost.
He doesn't know what to do without her.
No, don't come in here.
Oh my god.
He really doesn't know what to do without her.
Okay.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Okay, I see the one.
I don't think I can get over there so fast.
Sorry, hold on.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, God, this is tough.
Wait.
Hello?
Okay.
I can't see it.
Oh.
All right.
Okay, run.
Ha.
Ha!
This
is the worst thing ever.
Oh, just kill me.
Just kill me.
Why couldn't I hack it, though?
Also, where did the alarm come from?
Oh, you.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
What's a hell zone in there?
I don't think I'm going to go back.
I don't know why I couldn't.
Okay, we'll give up on there for now.
And we'll follow the arrow.
Follow the arrow.
Follow what we were supposed to do.
Oh, her head is a little funky.
Are you coming over here?
Oh, come on.
Please.
No!
I need to go over there!
Her head is like freaking out.
Use daddy as a shield.
You know what?
Oh.
I need to take your guy for a bit.
Actually!
Can he handle this in here for me?
Sick him!
Sick him, boy!
Sick him?
Sick him, boy.
Sick him.
I can't see anything.
I just hear it.
Oh, he blew it up.
Good job.
Now get the other one.
Wait, did you?
Wait, I think you already got it.
Oh, crazy.
Wait, excuse me.
Excuse me?
Did you already get it?
Oh.
Ah!
Sorry.
Okay.
Excuse me.
That was so scary!
There we go.
Oh wait, no.
I need you first.
Luckily, this is an easy one.
I'm all stressed out.
Thank you.
Broken vending machine.
So sad.
Oh, is he back to normal?
Okay, he's back to normal.
Thank you so much for your help.
I think I'm gonna save because that was like...
hell to go through.
Rip the circus of values.
He's gotta go get his little sister back.
Yeah, thanks Mr. Bubbles.
He did get this one down here, right?
Oh.
You sure did.
Oh, I can't carry anymore.
I need to start using my stuff.
My goodness.
Don't come wanting to me about Market forces and don't
expect me to punish citizens for showing a little
initiative.
It did have a zapable switch.
Yes, it did.
Well, I suggest you find a way to offer a better product.
I don't know where the lady went.
Just give me a minute.
Journey Lazarus tests are very important.
If the Rosagallica moves, then my god, I know we're in
business.
Hurry the lockdown!
All right, I'm leaving!
Very important.
are very...
Oh my god!
Okay, well also, there's like a bot shut down right here.
Oh my god, I didn't see that thing at all.
Flashbang, I...
Oh my god.
You guys, I'm not good out for this, I think.
Oh, awesome.
Um, I would like to go up, actually.
And over.
Just a little fire.
We're fine, maybe.
What's in the handbag, queen?
Hello?
I'm trying to take everything.
Why won't it take the money?
My wallet is full?
What do you mean my wallet is full?
What?
Okay, let's go buy a bunch of stuff.
But there's no...
Oh.
Okay, that doesn't work.
Shopping spree!
I'm a hoarder for real.
You guys know this, though.
Maybe you don't know if you're watching me.
If you're, like, a newer watcher.
But yeah, I'm a hoarder.
If you couldn't tell.
already.
The admin stands for money.
Was there one out here?
It's not there.
Where was the last one we saw?
Oh, I hear him.
He's on the other side of this wall.
Circus of values.
Where was he?
Excuse me.
me.
May I pass?
May I?
Oh, she's back.
Oh, come on.
What about over here?
Oh, oh, this is... Oh, oh, nice, nice.
Okay.
We can't get through.
What is all of this?
Oh, no.
Randru believes in horoscopes or some...
Oh, it's just a blowy.
Um, yeah.
This the way, this the way, this the way.
Do you guys believe in horoscopes?
I believe in horror.
Horoscopes.
Was it in... Where was it?
Okay, hold on.
Around this corner.
Circus of valley!
You?
Where am I?
No.
What?
Is it upstairs?
Oh, what's up?
Oh, I know where we are.
Yeah, over here.
Right here.
Failure.
26.
I mean...
I don't...
I'm just buying anything at this point.
I cannot carry any more of this.
I don't have the chemical flame thrower yet.
Fill her up!
I guess we could, right?
Alright, big spending.
Big spending, everybody.
Oh, I thought I saw something in there.
A circus of valley.
Oh.
Wait.
All right.
Backtracked a little bit.
But now we're back.
What is...
Oh, that's the drone.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Where was...
Where were we?
Oh, I wanted to go that way.
But I think, um...
Big Daddy was around or something.
So we'll go this way now.
and pray that they're not here.
Oh, that's right.
There was a security camera.
I think I see it.
All right.
We'll grab it.
We'll get it.
Uh.
That was terrifying.
I don't want to waste my pistol.
No.
Wait, I could take a picture of it.
Have I not?
Oh!
Oops.
That works.
I suppose.
You.
Let's do this.
All right.
Little zapper.
Did I get it?
No.
Oh my god!
Maybe this would instead.
I think I did the wrong one.
Okay.
Alright.
We do it again.
I'm sorry!
I didn't hit her!
I didn't touch her pretty little head!
Where's she going?
To the...
Oh.
I can see the angels dancing.
What am I, a monkey to you?
She's dancing.
She's moonwalking?
So is he?
No, no, no, no.
I don't think you're gonna find angels that way.
Oh my god, she's actually like...
I can smell another angel.
They're actually like, spawn camping me right now.
I can hear the flap, flap, flap of an angel.
Damn.
Is she stuck or...
Is there a way that I can, um...
Might need to spook them?
Uh, I could go down this way.
But I need to go that way!
She's glitched!
Okay, hold on.
Let's just, uh, let's just go down this way and see what
happens.
know we don't need to go that way who needs to go that way
who needs um we
all make choices but in the end our choices make us oh look
there's also another thing here oh i can't oh my gosh i
can't pick up anymore that's crazy welcome to the circus of
value Yeah, that way sucks.
We don't...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
It's fine as long as...
No, we can't get too close, right?
We're hacking.
Sorry, I wanted to save because it said it was difficult.
I don't know.
My brain is like a little...
Uh...
This way.
Ooh, oh, okay.
We're gonna have to do a little loop-de-loop here.
Oh my gosh.
It's fast, actually.
It's actually kind of fast.
Oh, you jerk.
Up, up, up, up, up, up.
Perfect, exactly what I needed.
Do we not have any ups?
Oh.
No way.
I have no up!
Just a single up!
Oh!
See, and this is why we say We saved everybody.
This is why we saved.
No upies.
Hey, you used them up.
I did.
I like, though, that these are gotcha.
Or rather, like, they're different every time.
So, if you get an unlucky...
if you're dealt an unlucky hand, it doesn't feel like you
are so, you know, SOL.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
Yeah, you can reroll because sometimes it really is like
unfair.
Who is Atlas?
We all make choices, but in the end, our choices make us.
You might hear things about me.
See,
mice.
Who is Atlas?
But it's just an excuse man used to kill one another.
Oh, he's a...
He's a broken man.
His family is dead by his own doing.
I'm so short, I think.
I think I'm...
I think I'm the shortest person ever.
Oh!
What's gonna happen in here?
Glue.
I like finding these crawl spaces.
It's pretty fun.
Alright, safe.
It's tough, guys.
It's a tough one.
Alright, this might be another one that takes a couple
tries.
It's a secret.
Alright, here we go.
I think I'm the shortest person ever, Minto.
Greetings, Minto.
Hello, catch up!
Am I eating the glue?
As a snack?
Oh geez, okay.
Oh no.
No way.
We couldn't- we lost before we even started.
That was rough.
Okay, one more try.
That was tough!
Alright.
Alright, start.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
No way!
Oh!
Actually, that would have led to a, uh, a dead end anyway.
Oh, hard safes are hard.
Alright, no, they're right.
This is easy peasy.
I've never used a...
Auto hack in my whole afterlife!
Please, just... There.
I've never had to use one!
Watch the goo flow.
$53 electric book
sounds right next to me
okay she's over there can I go through here oh wait let me
save since I just did that real quick sorry not bad
yeah I do need to take more pictures I'm really bad about
it.
Actually, we don't need to hack this one right now.
What is that?
Oh, destroyed security camera.
Wait.
Oh.
That's the one I did.
Bring me more photos of Spider-Man.
On the surface, I once bought a forest.
The parasites claimed that the land belonged to God and
demanded that I establish a public park there.
Why?
So the rebel could stand slack-jawed onto the canopy and
pretend that it was paradise earned.
This is a crazy park.
Congress moved to nationalize my forest.
I burnt it to the ground.
God did not plant the seeds of this Arcadia.
I did.
There he is.
He's teeny tiny.
I get like nothing for it.
I think that's also why.
Because I'm just like, oh wait.
I get like nothing for it.
And then it's also like, you know.
Oh, wait.
Oh my god.
I just realized what it was.
Oh.
Oh, there's like...
There's stuff up there.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Ready?
Watch this.
Why is it max hard?
Oh!
Okay.
Alright, we got this.
Oh my god, wait.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
What is this?
is that?
Wait, does it go really fast when you use it?
Well, I guess I'll find out.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no.
There we go.
Up!
Upies!
Upies, upies, upies, upies!
Upies, upies, upies!
Oh, it slows it.
First try.
Eh, it might be a genius or something.
The hardest difficulty.
First try.
If only I had telekinesis right now.
I could grab it.
Oh wait, I can grab it.
Yeah, there was another one.
Oh, something over here.
Oh, I think that's cash money, baby.
Who is crying?
around whistling and crying and pissing and shitting $8
she's got hops where'd you come from okay we got to be
careful of this guy because he will shoot us and won't be
very fun at all what's so wrong with that I'm hopping I'm
hopping, you can't stop me!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Anytime it gives me an automatic hack tool, I kind of get
sad.
I don't want that.
Oh, oh, oh my god.
Oh, I almost took you out.
I mean, you would have taken me out.
But I almost tried to take you out.
Save?
Didn't I save?
again.
This guy's standing right in front of me.
I love the minigame.
I love minigame.
I love puzzle game.
Especially, you know.
The minute we came here, now I should start screaming.
Mama, mama, what?
I thought she was having some kind of seizure.
And then I realized...
I never saw one before.
I thought they were monsters.
Aww.
Oh, Sammy.
Maybe we never should have come to this place.
Yeah, you didn't think that your kid growing up in the
underwater facility would have never seen a tree before?
Does this...
Scarecrow have big old booba?
Now, who made this?
masterpiece
I see a security camera I wish I could turn off some of
these effects you know what I mean like the fuck oh this is
not good
but I think Ryan has just killed Arcadia foul into the air
yeah
Oh no!
Ryan's woman in Arcadia is an old Betty named Langford.
Wait, there's like big tinny ladies in the trees!
Um, find Julie Langford.
Okay, I thought I was gonna get poisoned and have like a
time limit thing.
Okay, I'm kind of glad it wasn't that though.
I'm a little relieved actually.
around right now.
How do I get up there?
Oh, I think I would probably need telekinesis, but...
Okay.
Yeah, good thing it wasn't that.
I was about to stress.
I was about to be stressed.
Oh, nope, that's...
Why did it do that?
Why is it doing that?
Oh, liquid nitrogen.
All right, so where...
We need to find Langford.
That's what it said.
So we go through here.
Perhaps.
Whoa, that was close.
Team!
Oh, oh, okay, oh shoot, that's tight.
Alright, uh, here we go.
Uh, uh, Eel.
And, uh, Eel.
I love games where you can hack things.
Me too!
So fun!
Coffee.
Pisto.
Oh, it's the armor.
It's the bullet.
El ammo bandito.
Yeah.
This one's always kind of stressed me out too though,
because you gotta get to them real fast.
And...
Oh.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
Wait!
You!
Wait, where's the L up there?
Uh-huh.
And you.
You.
Poof!
Taking the scenic route.
Where are they anyway?
I wonder how much I get Oh, it was a bee
Okay I could sell some ammo Can you?
No, I don't think you're even on the purchase
I use my pistol a lot by a little bit more.
No!
Ryan.
I think I've gone away to save the trees.
It's a genetic Oh my god.
She's the Lorax.
Julie Lorax.
Could you find a sample of Rosa Gallica for me?
Look in the grotto.
I've got to keep working on this time.
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh my god!
The tree!
and the crabs!
That's so fun.
In the bubbles.
Where did that guy come from?
This was our home, is that what he did?
Oh!
I thought the fire was supposed to spread.
Try not to shoot too hard.
I guess I could have let this guy take care of her.
I didn't mean to eat the cake.
I only clicked once.
Alright, we gotta go find the rose, right?
There should be two of you guys walking around so I can take
you both.
You're so loud.
I guess I'm just following after him.
Did she go to bed?
I think so.
You might be able to see the symbols on the wall now that
the plants are gone.
I did notice that some of them you can.
Yeah, like this.
But I don't...
I don't think it's anything.
Actually, maybe.
Oh wait, because...
You know what?
We'll just, like, hang out with him.
And if we need to...
We'll steal him.
He'll be ours.
We'll just follow him.
Why'd those catch on fire?
Oh, is that the way I need to go?
No.
I could go that way, I suppose.
It's so gross in there now.
I'm just confused.
Is it a ghost?
Time to follow.
Chlorophylls.
Wait, can I get a picture of you?
Oh, wrong thing.
Where'd you go?
Oh!
That should be an A.
What?
Action shot.
You scared me.
They're like weird cultists.
Not close enough.
Oh, well.
Kind of cool, though.
Yeah.
I can't see.
I'm too sure.
Oh, sorry, I didn't mean to.
Sorry.
I didn't mean to...
Ah, sorry.
Your display.
Sorry.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to.
Is that all that's in here?
It's just some freaky stuff.
And a little...
There's just a lot of, uh...
A lot of alcohol.
Alright.
That's fun too.
Oh wait.
Cool.
We take those.
I gotta be mining and crafting soon.
Wait, where are you going?
You were supposed to be my bodyguard!
Dancing.
Oh, she's back.
actually guys i have to use the little ghosty's room i'm
sorry i will be like right back real quick right fast right
fast right fast
save yeah we can save well i did save just before going into
that room but we'll save again potty break a potty break
okay i know there's water everywhere it's hard not to want
to go it that way but maybe it's like a subconscious yeah
maybe i'm like wow water water water water oh no water water
water um and i'm also gonna go grab more tea as well so i'll
be just a second we are we we're back
what was that face i was making
oh what was that one second let me make sure my cat I didn't
get into the room.
She's not.
Paranormal levels of smug.
Levels we have never reached before.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's go.
Let's keep going.
Alright, so we are headed this way.
We gotta go find a rose or something.
I could hear both of them.
like moaning, groaning at the same time.
So, was it in the...
Where'd he go?
Oh, he's trying to heal!
That's what it's saying.
No!
I won't let you!
Wait, where'd he go?
Oh, he died.
I got his butt.
Yeah.
Oh, so I should hack this.
Oh, if you hack them, it will hurt them.
Birth, birth, birth.
No!
Death,
death.
I don't know where I'm hearing them from.
Where'd that lady's body go?
Oh, is that her?
Is this you?
Kill you and take your money.
I love hearing the little sisters talk.
They're just too cute.
Oh, wait.
All right.
Oh, okay.
There we go.
Big jump.
Can I get around you, please?
What is she doing?
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to save real quick.
I don't want to aggro him, but I will try going by them and
seeing what happens.
I can get that close!
Oh my gosh, I've been being way overly careful, huh, haven't
I?
That's so funny.
Okay, oh, in here.
Alright.
Oh, there was that one door that I didn't go through.
What must rapture smell like?
With all the seawater and Minto cooking people?
Ew!
The cooking people is, uh, that's gonna be pretty bad, I
admit.
That will be pretty bad.
Is this a trap?
Wait a second.
Nope.
Hey, you're mine now?
So come on in.
I don't like this area.
Security evasion.
Has a rival faction set up security cameras and turrets
where you need to go?
Security evasion adjusts the thermal signature of your
epidermal layer, confusing cameras and turrets and delaying
their response.
I'm gonna store in the gene bank what's this one doing?
Eve Link oh that one is if I use a med kit I get Eve this is
when I hack I get Eve and health
it's a mid yeah okay we'll put it in the gene bank then
alright let's go
I think I've done everything in here, though, unless they
re-hacked it.
I might have just taken you for nothing.
Here, come on, buddy.
Let's go through here.
There's another cat!
Wait, is this where I'm supposed to be?
No.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Please stop walking.
Supposed to be in here, or...
Ryan, how could he do such things to innocent?
I think I need this.
Okay, now, buddy, protect me.
Shoot me, I dare you.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God, you're still up.
The clap of his cheeks is too powerful enough.
Why me?
Why, no!
No!
Why did he outgrow on me?
Why?
I guess I maybe accidentally shot him.
Well, we got a shortcut, so...
We got a shortcut.
where'd he go holy cow scared that no you didn't beat up my
thing did you you hunt no sounds like she's saying skeddy
skeddy with delayed flip oh my god wait mr.
B she's ready for dream time mr.
B
Is there anything in here?
Oh, what is this?
They dress up in leaves and call themselves the Saturnine.
They drink human blood and chant.
Harness the flame, harness the mist, and believe they're
touched by the ancient god.
Oh.
An aging bunch of frat boys.
This is the...
Harness the mint.
And calling it Ambrosia.
Ha ha ha.
Wait, hold on.
I know there's gonna be one of these...
One of these splicers.
One of the Houdini splicers in here.
I know how this game plays now.
Can I freeze him?
I wonder.
Spooky.
Try it.
They're gonna burn out, right?
Yeah.
That's not me, right?
Do you
have anything in there?
Oh.
More chlorophyll.
If I touch this...
Can it ambush me?
Hmm.
My hand hurts.
Tis a flash wound.
Oh, Halloween pumpkin.
all right take pictures of this does this count
no of this miss fight this is my muse
i wonder who triggered what oh yes you are here i knew it
Did I get him?
Oh.
What is going on?
He's dead.
I knew it.
I knew that it would happen.
I called it.
Are we good, then?
Will you let us in, lady?
You let us in?
Put the flower in the hole?
Yeah.
What are you waiting for?
An engraved invitation?
Send it through the NUMO.
The NUMO?
I don't know what it is about the NUMO, but if it looks
very...
This is perfect.
Um...
Perfect.
Come on up to my office.
I'm letting you in the house.
It looks very Dr. Who to me.
I can't...
Hacking expert.
I'm already a hacking expert.
Like a Dalek?
Oh, maybe, maybe.
I've been kind of wanting to watch.
I've never watched Doctor Who before.
I know, like, a little bit about it.
But I've been wanting to watch, like, the series recently.
I've been getting a lot of clips from it.
And I'm like, wow, this looks so...
This looks so fun.
I keep getting Doctor Who shorts.
I don't know.
Maybe there's, like, a resurgence of Doctor Who recently or
something.
It's a British One Piece?
It's a very bizarre show at times, but it's good.
Yeah.
The early seasons are pretty fun.
It'll make me British?
Maybe I shouldn't then.
The original hack-smart gene tonic.
Hacking expert diffuses alarms and helps avoid overloads.
It's a must-have plasmid of the hack-smart line.
Nah, nah, no.
I don't need to.
Professor Holden Langford recently.
search laboratories.
Laboratories.
Isn't there anything in this damn place those pagans won't
steal?
Paper towels, ink pots, witch hazel, chlorophyll solutions,
even my back issues of national geographic.
I took the chlorophyll solution, but she said it.
Wait.
They drink human blood and chant.
Harness the flame.
Wait, but I just, wait, what just happened?
And believe they're touched by the ancient god.
Yes.
An aging bunch of frat boys tilting back goblets of plasmids
and calling it ambrosia why is there a timer wait hold on
i'm scared now this baddie plant woman spends four years
coming up with ways to defoliate trees in the pacific to
scare out the japs and now here i am down at the bottom of
the atlantic trying to figure out how to do the same thing
in reverse Adam's Adam it's backed up gene times the atom
bomb times is this her no who's that uh hello oh okay we
made it Mr Ryan industries maintains exclusive rights to the
creation use and exploitation of the Latin sector ownership
no please Oh,
we're dying a message.
Oh.
Oh, I shouldn't be going in there, right?
I'm hearing so
much happening.
9, 4, 5, 7?
The Lazarus.
What is that?
I've been killing trees for 25.
Oh, the chemical thrower!
Oh,
she's been up here the whole time.
Maybe it'll bring the old gal's career back from the dead as
well.
Okay.
She had two whole dollars on her.
Look, how much did she need?
Truly.
Treeflow, a tea garden, waterfall, tree farm, market rolling
hills.
It's going bonkers.
Use?
Wait, hold on.
All right, take it all.
Search containers for loot.
What do you think I'm doing, game?
All right, before I pick up that, well, actually, we can
probably pick this up.
ammo against targets vulnerable to cold.
I don't know who's vulnerable to cold, though.
Alright, I'm gonna save and then we shall do whatever the
painting does.
Yeah, the game is crazy with the back savings.
So funny.
9457.
I was gonna see if it would let me hack it.
Just for fun.
Just for funsies, you know?
I might be addicted.
The Lazarus Vector Formula.
Oh, the market key.
And $27.
What's the point of being a damn genius if the only ones
around to appreciate it are a bunch of spliced up morons?
I've cracked the Vector.
Or at least I'm 99% certain I have.
I just need a bud of rose and gallicol.
to confirm my analysis.
Distilled water, a bit of chlorophyll, and enzymes extracted
from Abyss Malifera.
That's right, sweetheart.
Honeybee spit.
One, two.
You have a multi-part goal.
Press M to see all parts of the goal and switch between
one... Which one is active?
The arrow and map will guide you to your active goal.
Invent the Lazarus vector?
Okay.
Wait.
It says press M, but that's the map.
Oh, this one, maybe.
Oh, obtain seven distilled water.
Seven enzyme samples.
Seven chlorophyll.
Oh, I got six out of seven.
All right.
What is active?
I haven't even found any of the other things, though.
Oh no, you guys!
Shut up, shut up, shut up!
Shut up!
I want to try.
Oh.
Wait, maybe I should have, uh, set up a map.
Come on.
Hello?
Dang.
I got her.
Run away!
Oh, take pictures, you're right!
Hello!
I know there's one guy, he's so around.
I don't think I killed him.
Wait.
Oh, there he is.
Come here.
Nice.
Oh.
Yeah, we got him.
I don't want to drink the coffee.
I just want to take their money.
electric bucked him yeah we did um okay this is not looking
so great where is the said turret all right we have two
things that we okay hold on i'm gonna save sorry uh because
we got two things we gotta worry about here you don't think
the coffee hurts it doesn't it take away health like it's
kind of like It takes away health, but gives you plasmid.
And then food gives you health, but takes plasmid.
Oh, no.
Oh, that's just alcohol.
Coffee is safe.
Oh, and the cigarettes.
Okay.
That's why I've been, like, so nervous about taking stuff.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, okay.
It's just smoking and alcohol.
Ah, that's why I'm...
been under the impression this whole time, and chips are
safe too.
Hello, buddy.
Wait, maybe I can hack it.
I was gonna see if I could hack it, and then... Oh, wait, I
don't think I can hack it.
It looks up too high up, doesn't it?
Maybe it's not too high up.
It looks kind of close, but I think I'm getting shot at.
Wait, there we go.
It's like, do I have anything that I can?
Oh, wait.
Actually, you know what that worked.
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la,
la, la, da, da, da, da, da.
Is that you mammal pod?
All right.
That's one issue out of the way.
Longest possible route.
Look.
We just take... Why am I crouched?
We take what we can get, alright?
It doesn't matter.
As long as we get there, no?
I would like to put this on my resume, honestly.
Can work under high stress scenarios.
Actually, will this work?
Yeah, we got this.
Easy.
Can work under high pressure.
Life or death.
Where did he go?
He was around and then...
Nape bomb!
Oh, it's this guy.
Where are you?
Oh!
They're so funny.
Where'd he go?
Did he die?
Oh, he died on me!
A wrench?
That's funny.
I could just pick up another wrench.
Ah, we got all the chlorophyll solution!
Okay.
But where do I...
Get everything else, you know?
Oh.
Her head is like...
glitching out again.
The weapon upgrades change the looks of the weapons.
Yeah, it looks really cool, no?
Gene bank.
What's in here?
Oh, circus of value!
Electric gel.
I don't know what that is.
Oh!
Why is it so hard?
I just saved, so maybe we can try.
Oh my gosh.
Uh...
Oh my god, I need one that goes up please?
Up?
Upies?
Upies.
Electrifying glue.
Right ball!
Welcome back!
Me too random!
Me
back!
Thank you!
Did I hack anything else?
Oh, hack, hack, hack.
Keep on hacking!
Don't stop Keep a hackin'.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Oh, come on.
Are you serious right now?
Oh.
Nice.
Yay!
Hacking, hacking!
What do we have in here anyway?
Circus of Values.
Pistol rounds.
I'll buy them.
It's only six.
Ouch.
Wait, I thought it was 45 of them.
I don't know what I was thinking.
It's okay.
I see number.
Whatever.
Taxologist.
I might be...
Wait, is that thing active?
I think it was.
It wasn't active before, I know that for sure.
Oh, holy cow.
There we go.
Well,
I have enough?
I will have enough.
Six shots is more than enough anyway.
So true!
They're 45 caliber, not $45.
I can't tell anymore.
I don't know anything anymore.
What am I hacking?
Oh, let's hack a heal station.
Yeah, oh my gosh, so much hacking!
So much hacking!
Yeah, kill!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go.
We're feeling good.
Maybe.
Okay.
I'm actually not feeling so good because I didn't get
literally any water or enzymes at all this entire time.
So I'm quite worried how to find them.
but the hacker meant phantom.
She scares me.
It's all back in the market.
Oh, that's right!
We got the key!
You are right!
Alright.
Where was the market?
This is the...
messed up...
Actually...
This is so messed up.
What a map.
I don't see who...
Raiden, but...
Hello!
Thank you.
Dargo, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much for the raid.
Hello!
I'm playing...
I'm playing Bioshock for the first time ever.
And, um...
Maybe I...
Okay.
Once I go through here, surely...
Arcadia is a big place, but mostly rural.
If you're looking for something to...
The farmer's market.
Bandages.
I don't need these.
Oh.
Hello.
Thank you.
Someone's humming.
I'll set them on fire.
Set the world on fire.
Someone's crying in there.
Bad.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't know you were coming through here.
My big daddy now.
This guy?
Not a problem.
Okay, he's dead!
He's dead!
Oh, here, the farmer's market.
I didn't even realize this was locked.
I don't think I even tried to go here before.
Cool.
Everybody knows you're here.
Go get his ass!
Good machine.
Oh, I can hack it.
Say no more.
I can hack it.
You want something hacked?
Yeah, I got you.
I got you.
Don't worry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You want something hacked?
Don't worry about it.
I'll handle it.
Yeah.
Yeah, I got you, I got you.
I destroyed it and it doesn't work anymore, but I can still
hack it.
Yeah, sure thing.
No!
Uh, wait, hold on.
Uh, shoot.
Uh.
Angels dancing.
I forgot to do this.
Die?
Oh, shoot.
Wait, hold on.
Uh.
Oh, my gosh.
Ouch.
Wait.
I think I'm in trouble.
I think we got her.
Maybe it...
Well, I guess I couldn't have taken him over because then I
would lose her and it would just kind of waste the other,
you know?
Even in the gathering dark you light a candle you have saved
the little ones.
Oh, I got like a it was like one out of two or something I'm
sending something your way to demonstrate our thanks Thanks
We will not touch this guy though.
Maybe unless we get another one.
Are you gonna leave?
Don't forget to take a picture.
Wait, can I take a picture of her?
Wait, oh.
Little sister.
She's just standing there.
What about you?
Oh, it's this guy.
I've taken pictures of so many of them.
I wish that like it.
Or better, but it's fine.
Oh my god!
You did such a good job.
I didn't even realize you died, though.
I'll take your money.
Wait, what's here?
I saw something glow it.
Oh, it's underneath here, isn't it?
A shotgun.
Okay.
Oh, switch off your armor piercing.
Thank you.
I had them, and I didn't even use them.
I got... I tried to...
I tried to use it, and then I was silly about it.
I'm sure we could bait somebody into...
that okay the gun is always empty nobody
give me the money wait give me the cash dollars oh wait i
gotta spend everything again we're almost to the max oh my
god collision
i gotta spend it all again
oh it's him glowing all right into here Arcadia, Rapture's
vacation land.
I didn't, how's my health, I wonder?
Yeah, we got alcohol on accident.
My health is like not, you know what?
Powered.
To the people.
What is this?
Oh, it's a weapon upgrade!
Oh!
exciting!
But what do I do?
I did my shotgun before.
I almost want to do the pistol damage increase.
I love my pistol.
Yeah, we could!
Honestly, the kickback reduction on the machine gun would be
huge too.
I've been using the machine gun a little bit more today.
I loved the shotgun one.
I used it a lot.
It's just so clean.
That's what I love about it.
It's just like a pew pew.
And it works so well.
I think I picked chemical thrower consumption on this one.
I gotta remember I have this guy.
Taper nozzle reduces the ammunition consumption rate of the
chemical thrower.
I think I went to... We will hold off on this one.
Because what I could do is use the chemical thrower a little
bit more and see if I want to upgrade it or how I would want
to upgrade it, you know what I mean?
So we'll do that.
Can I take just the battery thing?
Circus of values!
Just do the pistol, it's always reliable, that's true,
that's true.
Serpent Lord, I hope you feel better, The revolver looks
sick when fully upgraded?
Don't tell me that.
Wait,
oh, this way.
And a little, ha-ha.
And a little, la-la.
Let's spend some money, baby.
Oh, this one doesn't have Eve.
Oh, I was right.
It is 45.
I was right earlier.
Yeah.
I guess I could buy another piece.
You know, can't ever have enough first aid kits, huh?
Wait.
I'm almost full of those anyway, so I shouldn't buy that.
And I'm full of that.
I'm full of it.
Yeah, it's 45 for 6.
Yeah, I read it right before.
Maybe you have some coffee?
Yeah.
Yeah, we're going to go.
picture me.
I have a lot of film.
I'm just like spending money so that I can collect more
money, you know what I mean?
Alright, that should be good.
Where is he?
Oh, freaky.
Maybe they died.
I have to wait for this to die down.
The fire here is really good because of all the oil
everywhere.
Sorry, again, I'm saving because I just bought some stuff
and I don't want to do it all over again.
It's really just a matter of like... How do I say?
Sure, I could go to the...
I could go to the thing and regenerate.
But at the same time...
Sometimes I use a bunch of items.
And I'm a hoarder, okay?
I'm a hoarder.
I'm a sicko.
Nope.
Ah, nope.
Wait.
I didn't save.
Okay.
That gives us a little bit more time.
There we go.
It didn't do as much.
as much damage as I thought it would, so we're okay.
Porter Phantom.
I know.
I know what I am.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oops, sorry.
There's a, there's a med kit in there.
Let us remember.
And let us continue.
Candy boys Delicious Somebody's crying Okay Oh sorry I don't
want to have to hack it again Anyway You can use a med kit I
don't think I need to Thursday
Thursday Found in violation Will be relocated to a
place I look at the genes all day long I never do I see the
blueprints of sin i could blame the germans but in truth i
did not find tormentors in the prison camp but kindred
spirits oh these children don't scare me like that i have a
walk in something inside that for most is beautiful and
natural but in me is an abomination my maternal instinct
what was that was that me
Yeah.
Whoa!
There we go!
I think that's just you cough in the air.
Tendenbaum worked with the bad guy, sadly.
Yeah, you kind of, I mean, she created the children, so...
It does feel like those Metal Gear flashbacks and four is so
funny.
The farmer is the market.
I'm trying to decide if I want to continue or...
Endime!
Tasha.
You want to spend time with my honeybees?
Well, I'm going to have to start charging you for the
pleasure.
If I come out one more time and find you lulling out there
amongst my hives...
I'm lulling?
I'm ruffling?
I'm LMAOing?
My days in beekeeping school are a blur.
But I do seem to remember something about that enzyme you
keep blabbing on about.
Wait, why are these playing over again?
This is the second time it's happened though.
Look at that honey.
Delicious.
There are duplicates.
Oh.
Cancel due to fire.
No.
The big game.
The Honey Bowl.
Cancel due to fire.
Oh my goodness.
Holy cow.
You're still beautiful, my queen.
I think there's a...
Where is it, though?
It sounds like one of the witches from Left 4 Dead, you
know?
That's what it reminds me of?
Oh, not one.
Holy hell.
Holy hell!
Okay, okay, okay.
I get it, I get it.
Yeah, the witch.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, we need to go that way, but, um, one moment.
There's board pressing matters.
Teetleetle.
I'm totally not stressing at all.
And this happy-go-lucky music is applying.
Everything is fine.
Yeah, I was hoping...
Okay, that's immediately why I got out of the way.
I had a feeling it immediately was gonna start shooting at
her.
Cool.
You're good now?
You calm down?
First class apples!
Photos!
Focus.
Subject is friendly!
Oh, okay.
Interesting.
Good to know.
Is it just the one?
I think so.
I don't see what Cheese Each save in Bioshock Remastered is
like 12 megabytes I wonder how many gigs are being taken out
of me It's hard drive but no It's fine I'll uninstall games
as soon as I beat them Creature kitchen I went back and
100%ed it And got the achievements last night And then I
uninstalled it I Uninstalled it
Just trying to see where it's at.
Hey, stop, stop!
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay, I see it.
Okay.
Meanto, the storage saver.
You might uninstall it from your PC, but the Circus of Val,
you will never leave your head.
That's so true.
Oh, wow.
It's really slow.
You work for me now, bud.
What's this?
Nothing.
Oh.
A surveillance camera.
Ah.
Should have known.
No, the cheese is...
How long has this place been, like, gone to hell?
Is what I wonder.
I mean, it feels fast and, like...
Oh, that's nice.
Okay, so...
I'm gonna save real quick and figure out a way that I want
to go.
Not long.
It went to hell fast, then.
How is the cheese so molded?
Let's hack you.
Good thing I just saved.
Oh,
no, no, no, no.
There you go.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, no, no.
No, no, it's all wrong, it's all wrong.
Okay.
There we go.
It's well-aged, extra sharp.
Cheese doesn't take that long to mold.
Really?
I guess if it's like...
Noise.
A $1!
I saw it this time.
Running, running, running, running.
I'm learning, you guys!
I'm learning!
I am overall, I feel like, like I'm getting more comfortable
with the game.
But it is still pretty spooky.
That's still kind of spooky.
What if the cheese is supposed to be molded?
We don't know.
We could charge people $5 to use the toilet and give those
same people superpowers or similar things you got.
father's but we've all placed our hand on the great chain of
endeavor my hand is on it fontaine's is on it we all pull it
and are pulled by it yes these children are an abomination
but it is not my hand alone on the chain that created them
no humans their little fingers were right there next to mine
oh yeah it's not my fault it's everybody's fault best friend
rapture certified why is this in the farmer's market
oh patty pad and meets the finest cuts All right, sorry, I'm
saving again because I did a lot of stuff.
I'm that lazy.
All right, they got the dog in them.
Don't say that.
Nobody lays a hand on me!
Oh, oh, Tim!
Yeah!
Is he dead?
I think that...
Oh.
Poor sap didn't make it.
Oh, this is a door.
Look at that.
Oh, there's just this little sister.
I just realized I only got...
Okay, we gotta watch out for the camera.
Why?
What is that?
In ten years in this dump, I've come to accept a very low
standard.
Oh, no, he's French!
Even at the bottom of this fish tank, a man must have
standards.
The pathetic trudeau done at Morley Winery has started
putting water into his terrible wine.
Water!
When I confronted him with this fact, he tells me, Pierre,
this is not to worry.
The water, she is distilled.
It could be worse.
I could take it right from the ocean.
It is this axe.
Oh, there's one!
Nice.
Okay, so this is where the distilled water is, and the
farmer's market is where the...
Oh, I already searched.
Is where the honey is?
Wait.
There's the enzyme samples.
Here is where the...
Okay, before I go, though, there was an area that I didn't
explore quite yet.
Back over here.
Oh, look at that.
Oh my gosh, I almost missed you.
Oh!
Value.
Oh, oh my god, it's a big old circle.
I'm so stupid.
Eve, Link 2.
Get more Eve with every first aid kit.
Oh!
The upgrade!
Wait.
Oh!
Nice!
It wasn't me.
Oh
my god.
What's going on?
I'll take that.
Thank you.
That was crazy!
Yeah, the turret almost got me again for real.
What is this now?
Oh, just a lamp.
Oh, come on.
I was just about to go down there.
Wait, what's his health at?
Oh, it barely made a scratch on him.
All right, let's make a big old circle as well.
Wait.
Where was this circle?
Wait, how did he get over there?
How do I get over there?
Oh, okay.
She's going to bed.
Wish I could watch you play my favorite game of all time, Me
Too, but I gotta sleep.
Giant Robot Fan, good night!
Don't you worry, the VOD will be here.
Hopefully, unless I get struck by first...
By, um...
What's it called, for some reason?
Music.
My turret's right there, though.
What about my turret?
Oh, okay, this one's really hard.
Alright, we got disguise.
Maybe?
Uh...
got this guys?
We got this guys?
Oh, we got this guys?
And this is why I save scum!
This is why!
That's not my fault!
I'm just gonna stop explaining myself.
What an insane Jen.
That That was craziness!
No!
Wait, imagine if it were like that again.
I can't get past this!
Don't worry, we have video evidence!
No, no auto-hack, no auto-hack.
Okay, alright, here we go, here we go, here we go, here we
go, here we go, here we go.
Here we go, here we go, here we go.
Um...
Uh...
Oh, here we go.
Yeah!
Surely not a third time.
No!
And let's hack our... invent thing.
I was hoping that like the, what's it called, would, um...
My...
Everything would kill...
Oh, oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, hold on.
I got a content trade.
Wait!
That takes a lot.
I was...
Okay, hold on.
I gotta save again.
Dang it.
I was hoping that the turret and the security camera
together would take down a big daddy, but it didn't really
do that.
No, it didn't.
Okay, there we go.
Good miss.
Wait, are you serious?
Wait, oh, here we go.
Yeah, I would have to change the first pie, but like, how
are you supposed to know?
Right?
Let's purchase some stuff.
Oh my god, I have so much stuff.
All right, let's make some things.
Exploding bug.
Anti-personnel pistol.
Armor piercing auto rounds.
12.
Yeah, we'll make that.
Ooh, invent an item.
Lazarus vector.
A newly invented chemical meant to restore...
Oh, this is what I need!
This is the...
Okay, this is what I need for...
the okay okay for her thing so we have to invent it here
good to know
all right sorry i'm gonna save again since i just hacked
those okay all right i thought i don't know i thought maybe
once i did it it would just work awesome Is this a...
Oh, I can't carry anymore.
She's blonde!
Wait, they're...
Oh my gosh, they're like actually little different children.
That's so cute.
Wow!
That's like such a fun touch, are they?
First aid.
I think we're okay for now with my...
Photo?
They're doing something.
Yeah!
Ow!
Sorry.
I
didn't mean to do that.
Ow!
Wait.
Is he coming after me now?
Oh no.
Aww.
You're fine, you're fine buddy.
Ah, whatever.
That guy ran straight past.
Okay, there's a...
Watch out for that.
Right there.
Oh my god.
Is this an electric?
Yeah.
Is there...
Oh, there it is.
It's like, what do you mean?
It's not searched.
Okay.
Alright.
Ten hours.
What about ten hours?
Oh!
Are you okay?
That was close.
That was close, wasn't it, guy?
Alright.
Thanks for your help, big buddy.
They should call him Big Buddy instead of Big Daddy.
He helped me out.
He's like, hey, hey kid, wake up.
Okay, they're crawling out of there.
Wake up.
Mr. Bubbles.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
Thanks, Mr. Bubbles.
Okay, where am I headed to?
I think I'm going up there.
I smell something nasty.
Oh, where is she?
The fire!
You're being so good!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait!
Why are you coming after me?
Uh-oh.
Um.
Shoot.
Can I?
still hypnotize him when he's aggroed
oh no stand and fight okay we can try and fight him I will
try I will save a new save and then uh wait wait
I almost said any healer.
Oh, I got him!
Yippee!
I was so...
I just...
In the end, I just...
You know what, that worked.
No, no, no, no.
I was so panicked.
I didn't even think about using any other bullets.
Exercise one out of one.
Yay!
Thank you for helping me.
You're welcome, bye bye!
Well, um, I didn't plan on doing that.
I'm ready for dream time, Mr. Bubbles.
I didn't plan on doing that, but it worked, I guess.
Was it him?
I heard that!
Oh, my gosh!
Oh, you're scaring me!
Don't do that!
Let's apply some bandages, yeah, we'll do that.
No!
I didn't mean to do that, but that's fine.
I think that's the register.
so oh oh why don't you have any money on my walk today I had
my first encounter with a pair of them he a lumbering
palooka and a foul-smelling diving suit and she an unwashed
moppet in a filthy pink smug her pallor was off probably
already robbed.
Oh, true.
And morbid.
It was a rather unpleasant aspect of a demeanor, as if she
were in an altogether different place than the rest of us.
I understand the need for such creatures.
I just wish they could make them more presentable.
Oh, my God.
He's so evil.
He's so mean.
Palookas and wuppets.
Wait.
This is probably...
Oh.
Not the... Oh, okay.
We're on fire.
I'm on fire.
Oh, there's a corpse here?
One of the children came and sat in my lap.
Aww.
I push her off.
I shan't get away from me.
Oh.
That's not...
I can see the animal moving out of the corner of her mouth.
It's thick and green.
Her filthy hair hanging in her face.
Dirty cloths.
I'm dead.
What's going on with in her eye?
I feel hatred like I never felt before in my chest.
I thought she lied to the kids.
I can barely breathe.
And suddenly I know it is not this child I hate.
Wait, I'm full of money again.
Oh my gosh, where'd you come from, Big Daddy?
The Little Sisters Orphanage.
In trouble time.
Leave your little girl the light and heated.
We just gotta buy more stuff.
Okay.
Why not?
Alright.
Suffering from success.
I'm at least...
I'm a hoarder, but at least I'm good at it.
Right?
I'm good at hoarding.
Just buy it all.
Where...
I was about to say it.
That would be a waste of money.
Alright, what's in here?
For the Bible tells me so...
Oh.
Oh, teddy bear.
Oh my gosh, I can't even carry anymore.
Oh my gosh, it distilled water!
That's huge!
Save for bio Yeah exactly I'm saving for the next game Duh
Duh
Wait Wait Uh Wait Oh here we go There we go
You're so noisy.
Mr. B, you're so noisy.
And you stomp so loud.
Did I search you?
I didn't.
I didn't rob you blind.
Hmm.
I've been using...
Well, actually, I haven't used any of these, have I?
I was going to say I've been using a lot of these, but no,
I've been using the anti-personnel ones for the machine gun.
Honestly, it's been doing me well though, but I should
probably save.
So let's go back to my pistol.
And we'll do...
Oh, I don't have many of these, do I?
Wait, who's that up there?
Who are you?
Got him.
Maybe I will buy some.
Maybe I will make some after all.
Alright.
I can be a pretty good shot when I try, you guys.
Oh, can I hack this?
Sorry.
I'm getting a little too excited.
Did you ever go back and get that gun upgrade?
I didn't, actually.
I probably should.
It's a toughie.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
Oh my god, it's fast.
No!
We were so close.
Yeah, the gun upgrade.
I remember.
Thank you.
It's really funny seeing my saves and being like, The last
time you saved, made a new save was two minutes ago.
That one was so close Uh Shoot Wait Uh Uh Da da da da da da
da da Da da da da da da da da da da Da da da da da da
Okay Oh that one does go faster I thought you guys said it
goes slower You liars
Oh I forgot to take Rosie's money Oh You liars and cheaters?
Telling me it went slower, but it goes faster.
I knew it goes faster.
There are enough of the upgrade stations to put both
upgrades on every gun unless you mess up with very specific
points.
I should go back and get it, though, before I forget.
I don't want to forget about it.
Hi.
Hello.
pass.
You're free, you're free to go, you're free to go.
Wait, did I check that?
Yeah.
Where was it?
Actually, now I think about it.
Where?
Was it back?
Back?
Wait.
Was it back here?
It was in Arcadia!
You'll pass it when you leave.
Oh, that's true.
We do have to go back to...
Um...
To make the thing and put it in, right?
I guess that's true.
That's fine.
Let's keep going.
What's this?
I can't use it.
The circus of our value!
Wait,
um...
Come on, there we go.
Surprise the game hasn't crashed yet.
Arcadia has the most crashes out of any area.
Quiznov, you're gonna jinx it.
You're gonna jinx it!
Ah!
That was close.
Also, let's hack this guy, too.
You're gonna jigsay!
Uh-huh.
And...
Keep zigzagging it, baby.
Good thing she saves a lot.
I really do!
And it's not just because of me being paranoid about this
kind of stuff.
It is also because I'm like...
I know the game.
crashes or at least that's what all the so many oh wow the
way I got her so many other reviews were like you got to be
careful with this game it'll crash any second so it isn't
just like me being like oh I'm paranoid oh
shoot are you me right now.
Oh, the fire is going to be my worst enemy.
I have to kill this guy just for fun.
Ouch.
Ouch, ouch.
Oh, my God.
His health is crazy.
Oh, he's not probably seeking, is he?
Oh, he's coming.
up here oh i'm so i'm so screwed wait i'm so screwed
oh the yeah machine gun let's do that
armor piercing i don't have many though just save you're
right you're right you know what let's just let's just load
that what a what a terrible thing to happen i don't want to
waste all my bullets on a guy that i don't need to fight you
know actually that if I could, um...
If I could, uh...
What's the word?
Control him if he's aggro.
Oh, that's okay.
Um...
Yeah, honestly, I just don't want to...
I don't want to watch the materials.
Let's just go the way that it's telling me to go.
For you!
For you, you son of a kid!
What?
Nice!
Ah!
That's not what I meant to do, but sure.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh, it's kind of hard.
Alright, we'll do our best.
Hypno and Mad?
Yeah, yeah.
You have rebalanced the ones and O's in your computer are
now protected from the game crashing!
Please don't be in auto.
don't auto doom me please I
like the sounds they remind me of what's it called Zumbini's
they remind me of Zumbini's oh search search search there
was a search there was a search that disappeared Search,
search, search.
More saves coming?
You betcha.
Let's get the save.
Oh, gosh.
These ones, though, I think, are worth saves coming.
Wait, this is not possible.
Batara, I love hacks.
I love hacking.
It's so fun, ain't it?
With the pipes?
Yeah.
Oh wait, no, no, no, no!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
What?
I might be the luckiest ever.
Question for I.
Okay, I don't know.
I don't look.
Tell me when I can look again.
No, give me more armor, piercing pistol rounds, please!
I'm saving?
No, not yet.
Oh, whatever.
Okay.
I haven't done something yet.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh, I have so much money!
I've got, like, the most amount of money, any...
I'm the richest person in Rapture, I think.
I can't pick up any more.
I'm the richest person ever!
Oh, smile, smiles, thank you.
Little sister's orphanage.
Bringing big smiles to little faces.
Yeah, I think I'm still like, I'm kind of slow at the game,
Matara, so I haven't really yet.
I haven't done so much.
Circus of value!
Wasn't there more money I was thinking here?
The whole point is to have so much fun, just go around.
I am!
I'm having fun just looking at everything.
Like this.
Fancy fruit.
Oh, I'm sorry, it's the fine for...
But this guy says it's fancy.
What is actually wrong with him?
Oh my god.
Oh, he's waking up.
Wait, I thought we got the little sister.
Is there gonna be another one?
This is mine.
Yeah, yeah.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Not me.
Oh.
Stupid.
Stupid head.
I just wanted to help.
Good job, team.
I'll take his money.
Yeah, I will.
Where's his weapon?
Did he have any of this?
Maybe not.
Where did that guy come from?
Anyway.
Oh.
Wait, I saw it.
Well, that's right!
We had to go in here!
I forgot!
Andrew Ryan asks you a simple question.
Are you a man or a slave?
I've come to the horrible realization.
This game counts as retro.
I think so.
Clash your medicine's where I can bring it!
Oh!
Oh, bees!
Bees!
Bees?
Oh, thank you for moving in for me.
Am I finally getting the bees?
Beers!
Oh, is this my prize?
The bees are my prize!
Oh, great.
He's throwing native cells and replacing them with unstable
stemming versions.
Oh.
While this very instability is what gives it, it's amazing.
Ow!
You need more and more Adam just to keep back the tide.
From a medical standpoint, this is...
Oh my gosh!
Michael, thank you so much for the favor to get to thank
you!
Are they gone?
I got gone by the bees.
She sounds like my mom.
Your mom.
Okay, what's this now?
200 Adam!
Safe Cracker.
One of Hacksmart's more popular offerings.
Safe Cracker lets you into places that they want you to keep
you out of.
Splice it now and get hacking.
Reduce...
Wait.
Reduce is difficulty when hacking safes and combo locks.
I like the difficulties.
Store it away, store it away.
Ugh, the book.
The bees!
Releases a swarm of stinging insects that attack multiple
enemies.
Wow!
The bees, the bees!
You know what?
I haven't used that frozen one at all.
Maybe I use the bees.
Here's my obligatory insect swarm simp post.
I mean, I can always get another plasmid sludge.
What else do we got in here, though?
Machine Buster.
Oh, no, these are all actually older ones.
Bees are good because they're easy to fire off.
Please use the bees.
The bees are busted.
I think I've been convinced.
Nothing clears a room like swarms of stinging hornets.
Warning, not recommended for users with allergies.
Goodbye, winter blast.
the past.
Unleash insects against groups of enemies.
You have bees and Tommy gun.
You are the pain.
Tommy gun.
I'm wondering again if I should unlock another slot.
I think engineering was the one that I don't have a lot of
things for, but we could always get the prices.
I have so much money, but later on I might not have so much
money.
I don't know.
We'll save for later.
We just got a ton of money.
I have so much money.
How we get more slots?
I want to, yeah, I want to see what my hand turns into.
Never hurts to have more slots.
Yeah, but should I have, like, a plasmid slot?
Physical tonic.
Maybe the physical tonic would be good.
combat too resist damage
wait do I not have anything ah maybe human I'm imagining
human inferno is maybe a physical trait guessing you save
the sisters yeah instead of harvesting I want to harvest
Matara have you played harvester before
I know harvesting gives more Not spending your atom is
basically making you play the game on increasing I know I
know Living card thank you for the flag get it Okay let's do
this
I'm gonna do the human infernal It's one or the other Wrench
jockey Oh I forgot I had this one Oh I...
I'm never gonna sneak up on these guys.
Let's be honest.
I'm never gonna sneak up on them.
I'm too stupid.
I can't do it.
Let's just... You know what?
Let's unlock another slot.
Let's spend the money, baby.
Wait, I've already watched this one.
Throw objects at foes.
You can even catch grenades and throw them back.
Yeah, we hardly use the wrench at all.
Exactly.
Curls, creatures, and objects back with a...
Horse road!
Ah!
I'm...
Security.
No, no, no.
Nothing about hacking.
Don't make hacking easier for me.
I enjoy the thrill of the difficulty.
Okay, wait.
Let me save real quick.
Sorry.
And then, let's check out my B-arm.
In the garden we are growing.
Whoa!
Ew!
Oh, it's terrible.
It's worse than I thought.
Oh, it's horrible.
Oh, ew.
This is really triggering my tropophobia.
Oh, it's disgusting.
In the garden we are growing.
Something, something, never knowing.
Wait.
All right, so now...
Oh, I can switch...
Wait, do these stack?
Do these stack?
They do.
Security evasion.
Those things were living in my roof.
The pain.
The thumbnail is killer, by the way.
Yeah, the artist did amazing.
job.
Scrounder.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I can hoard even more!
Hard things!
You'll swear you have X-ray vision.
I can take all the things.
Let's try it.
We can always come back and switch.
What's this one do?
Oh, plasmids.
Yeah, we want to keep it.
That's a knot.
Yes, we want to keep these.
Hey!
This pleases my...
Peppy bar.
This pleases my hoarding heart.
Wait, so if I release these guys, do they like me now?
Be honest.
Actually, I know you guys won't be honest.
Oh.
I can't take it.
Oh, they will?
I don't know.
I don't...
Arden, they are growing.
Smoker control.
This will put them to sleep.
Wait, let's try it.
Ouch, they hate me.
Go to sleep.
Wait, what about my bees?
Oh, that sounds like a timer.
Maybe I'll...
Uh, wait.
Uh, I don't like the timer sound.
Wait, it's kind of scaring me.
I'm understanding how much time I have.
I'm gonna let it reset.
I'm gonna let it, okay.
And then I'm gonna get another one.
Empedomies!
Thank you!
What if Ivoos crawled on your arm like that?
Go defend me, Ivoos!
And then cataclysis, like a Pokemon.
I definitely could do that.
Thank you so much for the hack, I super!
Thank you.
Alright, let's go in.
Go to sleep, little babies.
There's so much stuff in here.
I can't even grab that.
The circus of...
What am I supposed to be grabbing anyway?
Um...
Uh oh, we gotta go.
Is there a door?
Did I miss?
Wait.
Oh, I'm supposed to search the hives for the honey!
That's right.
Search the beehives.
Ah!
Search again.
Stop it!
Seriously?
Okay.
This
guy is coming at me for...
Yeah, you're my bees.
You like me.
You aren't those stinking bees.
After Bioshock, Shock, Rainbow Six, Snake, you are
qualified.
What do you mean?
Let me take your two dollars.
they liked me.
I like the bee.
I'm one of you.
Look at my arm.
Alright, we searched these ones.
Let's go in for the...
I think they're having a hard time over there.
They're gonna get gouged by the bees though.
Come here, you.
Oh
my god.
I hate that my wrench and my thing switched.
my wrench and my pistol switched and it throws me off every
time actually let's go back to my this one so we can use the
electric bucks that I haven't been able to use anyway oh my
gosh how many do I have
I have 5 out of 7 yeah I do have the normal ammo I bought a
lot of the Is this thing going to go off for?
Five, seven.
Not six out of seven?
No, definitely not.
I definitely checked.
Well, this is...
I don't...
This is kind of annoying, isn't it?
Um...
I need to get to the other side.
Oh my god, I did it again.
Let's see.
We're okay!
I think?
It'll help against the next wave.
That is very true.
But at the same time, I can handle them.
It's still going.
Still going.
Take that.
You guys got a lot of stuff on you.
Okay.
Alright, then let me set up with this and this and go.
Go, go, go!
No, ouch.
I'm the star!
Oh, I think I got him all.
Ouch!
Oh!
Who's shooting me?
Oh, I can't go this way.
I mean, I could, but...
Oh no!
The bees!
The hive!
Oh no!
Wait!
It's gonna spread!
I think we got all of them, though.
Right?
Yes, now we just need the distilled water.
Good job, team!
Ching!
Book one step in.
Alright.
Let's save because we just did it.
Not the bees.
And now we switch.
Which one is bees?
F4 is bees.
I can't wait to use it.
We're
in the winery.
Everyone's gonna be...
White girl's wasted.
Oh.
Mwine?
Oh, I'm gonna get copyright struck again.
Ah, da-da-da-da-da.
Wait, you.
Ugh, I need a stretch.
Ah!
It's inevitable with this game, sadly.
Yeah, it's okay, though.
Ah!
I think they did that on purpose, huh?
They know.
Wait, no, I want to be you.
Not be you, but I want to use the bees on you.
There we go.
Holy cow!
Oh, whoops.
There we go.
Uh, wait.
Just a little over more.
Yeah, yeah.
There we go, there we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
I like this part because I can kind of just take a break for
a second.
At the end of the game, we need to count how many saves you
have.
Yeah, but sometimes I save over them.
I'm not consistent.
And then let's go get this health thing so they can't heal
themselves.
I'm gonna be a...
I'm gonna be a stone.
Uh-huh.
There we go.
We could always check them on.
True.
You could... There's one.
Alright.
Let's start saving again.
Saves are meant to be used.
So true!
Uh, it was F4.
Alright, F5 is telekinesis, which I never used, but...
Three out of seven.
I don't know why I went this way.
That's fine.
Oh, I thought I heard her.
So I know, for the Bible tells me so.
The children must remain functional to the environment.
Functional.
I had hoped we placed them into vegetative states so they
would be more pliable.
I find being around them very uncomfortable.
Even with those things implanted in their belly, they are
still children.
They are still children.
Tenden Bomb really is the Naomi of this game, isn't she?
Sometimes they...
Look at me.
I don't stop.
Oh.
Sometimes they smile.
Oh, it's like they like you or something.
Imagine that.
You guys?
I love the Circus of Values.
What a deal.
The Circus of Values.
It's the Circus of Values.
Like you guys use the clowny move.
What can we get?
We can give some value.
Drink up, drink up, drink up.
It's so bad.
I can't buy anything.
Why can't I buy the other thing that's not the proximity
mine so that I can actually use it?
Is there anything over here?
There's a safe here!
a tough one guys this is the thing about the saves the safes
is i save before them because usually they have like that
teeny tiny thing at the beginning and you can never tell if
you're gonna be able to make it or not you know uh like now
right uh yeah see
and we've been punked before yeah we have now the loop but
the star is brutal.
That's okay.
I enjoy the challenge.
Like so.
Oh, uh, sh- Oh, no, no, wait.
No!
Ah!
Holy cow!
That nearly killed us.
One HP and a dream.
Nexus, welcome back.
Thank you!
I really love the hackthole.
We're so screwed.
We're...
Fine.
I don't care.
You know what?
Let's just do it again.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
This one I'm not gonna entertain.
Last year I told you about me having a new sibling.
Baby Ibu is her first birthday!
My goodness, that's so...
Happy birthday to your baby sister!
Happy birthday!
That's so cute.
Oh, wait, wait a second.
Uh, wait a second, wait a second.
There we go.
Sweet little babe.
Oh, no, no, wait.
Actually, this one's impossible too.
This one's impossible.
The ones that end up being impossible are definitely the
rudest ones, I'd say.
Like here.
Wait.
Wait, wait.
We might be able to save this.
No!
Dang it, I was so close.
I didn't have anything to do it.
I think we're about to die, actually.
Oh!
That's okay, I'll just reload if I die again.
Oh, uh, like now.
Oh, shoot.
Like now.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
No, no, no, no.
I won't.
I don't.
I want to live.
Ah, baby!
Oh, my God, there were two distilled waters in there.
That's huge.
Wait, let me.
take the cash money?
Oh, my wallet is full.
Wait, uh, there we go.
Can I have that?
Thank you.
Alright.
Gosh, that one was tough, wasn't it?
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Minto's no coward.
I will never auto have Ever!
You won't see me auto-hacking!
Okay, I can't wait to use the bees.
First time using bees.
Let's go!
Oh.
What the hell, man?
What?
Is it gotta be this one?
Oh, that's why.
My bad.
Um, back to this.
Nope.
Wait, I only need one more now.
That's kind of crazy.
Why does the music get all crazy?
I collected an alcohol.
Above me.
No, I got it.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright, first time using bees.
Let's go.
Where are they?
All I do is hear them.
This guy's still getting still at it.
My bees!
It shocked you guys, didn't it?
My bees were very shocking.
Surprise bees!
You're still cute!
I love the flapper hair, like, hairstyle.
Come on, baby!
Oh, I didn't mean to drink that.
I thought it was a pistol.
There's our last one.
We're surely gonna get ambushed after that, right?
Oh, I hear him now.
Alright, sick.
say real quick.
Water in the wine.
Um, I'm gonna hack?
Start our hacking process!
It's... Oh, that's...
It's so fun!
We're doing the hacking process.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh.
Uh... Oh, wait.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, Uh, uh, uh, uh, Wait!
No!
Ouch.
Hold on.
Let me retry it again.
Educational TV theme song.
Ouch.
Of me as I know.
Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da
da da da da da da da da This might be the long way, but it's
okay.
Wait, I need...
Wait, I need more.
Oh, oh, oh.
You...
Oh, we got this.
Oh, please, please, please.
Ah!
What can I invent?
Give me...
I can invent the Lazarus of Ecton.
I forgot I could do that.
I forgot I needed it.
Oh, that's why they put it right there.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
Pistol rounds.
Yeah.
Oh, this is how many that you can buy.
Okay, I was wondering because I was like, wait, does it cost
money as well?
But I guess not.
That's so interesting.
Okay.
I don't know how many I have, that's the issue, it doesn't
say.
Yes,
sir.
You drop the vector into a gadget called Central Mist in
Control.
Then we'll be cooking with gas.
Do I want to...
I'm trying to decide if I...
Sorry, I'm just going to save so I don't have to redo it.
down there or why is there just gas in this tiny like
someone farted and it's lingering I'm gonna make another
Lazarus I'm gonna leave do I really need to explore down
here
totes explore okay Okay, but he's like in my way.
Wait for him to pass?
Yeah, there might be a weapon upgrade.
You're so right.
Ew, the hand looks so nasty.
Are you gonna come up here or?
Yeah, you are.
Yeah, okay.
All right, big guy.
Good job, team.
I really need him to get out of my way.
Large father.
Yeah, I know.
It's so hard being you.
You're just a big, heavy guy.
Don't turn around.
Yeah, yeah.
Keep coming up.
Alright, yep.
Making my way downtown.
Walking slow.
Okay, turning this way towards me.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
okay this is gonna sound really silly but i am gonna save so
that we don't have to wait for him to come all the way back
upstairs again this is my this is how my mental works okay
do i i don't need it anymore but it's kind of fun no oh
there's one of these things here
oh goodness the only thing that was holding him together
Bees!
Oh.
My bees are afraid of windows, I think.
Where the hell are you?
They're so scary, but they like sound like absolute weenies.
It's so funny.
Wait, that is so...
Oh, and he's back.
Alright, let's go down.
Oh, who's that?
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Was there a thing?
Oh, there is, there is.
No!
You...
Why is he after me?
Just too much power.
Ah!
Okay.
Actually, we can just die to him.
Because the thing is right there.
It's fine.
I don't mind.
I'm not afraid of death.
We'll be okay, everybody.
We'll be all right.
Don't worry about it.
Wait.
There we go.
This is the one I was looking for.
Wait, I think he doesn't care anymore.
Yay, we're okay!
He doesn't care!
For now then, while he's around, we just won't use the
beast.
We'll just, uh...
Yeah, yellow means chill.
We're chill, we're chill, we're chill.
We're chill, we're chill.
There's some guy.
He won't stop yapping.
No way.
Is that actually a weapon?
Wait.
No, it's a gene bank.
But still.
Wait, we have some other stuff here, though.
I'm sorry to get hungry, finally.
But you know what?
This might be a good time to, well...
Photographer's eye.
Every research photographer wants an edge, and
photographer's eye is yours.
Once you've spliced this invaluable gene tonic, you'll get
the picture.
What does that mean?
Oh, we increase his research score.
Oh, that's good.
Oh.
I should probably switch back for my electric bucks.
What does that sound?
What's the awuga?
What's the awuga all about?
It's also a guy over there.
Ah, it is a gene bank.
There's a lot of water down here.
I just keep grabbing it all.
Who knows?
It's kind of fun to collect.
Oh, wait.
If I'm in the water, if they're in the water, it's great.
If I'm also in the water, it's not so good.
Baby.
What is that?
Why not?
Wait, this is a weapons upgrade.
Oh, it's a weapons upgrade.
The awulga is me when I see me darn black maid outfit.
I actually really like wearing it.
I feel like it goes a while with my hair.
End of my eyes.
Let's see.
Alright, now we have two that we can do.
I haven't done the chemical thrower.
Not even once.
it once but not even twice pistol machine gun let's do
shoddy let's do pistol and then the next one we can do the
machine actually no let's do machine gun and then the next
one we can do is the pistol I think Right?
Rate of fire is pretty big though for the shotgun though.
But I've been using the machine gun a lot more.
So let's go with the damage for the machine gun.
Strong.
I don't know where this guy has been at this entire time.
Oh!
Okay.
God, they're noisy.
Oh, what's back here?
Uh...
No.
Wait.
You know, I'm realizing I'm such a silly goose.
When Big Daddy is walking around and he's in my way and I
don't want to bother him, I should turn him into my slave.
I think he likes the sound of the idea.
I think he likes that idea Bees
Oh Good job, bees
Wow, they give you so many options They give you so many
options for, uh
for like getting the distilled water.
That's really nice.
There we go, finally.
Holy cow.
We role play in the pain?
Absolutely.
These are good for pictures, are they?
Oh yeah, I do have like that new upgrade now, don't I?
Oh, huge!
Huge!
Oh,
exploring is great.
Oh, oh, that's nothing.
Where are these things anyway?
Oh,
yeah, go get up!
The girls are fighting.
Good job, team.
Stupid head.
And I'll take your pistone.
Alright, uh, how do I get back upstairs?
We'll follow him.
Sorry, can I get around you?
Oh, okay, you're going.
Sure, sure thing.
You're fine.
Sorry, my bad.
What's up here?
Oh,
they just...
They just unload on him.
Oh, oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
We need to get out of here.
Why would you do that?
These!
Yeah, I wanted to get out of there because I think Big Daddy
was coming up the stairs or something, and he was gonna get
bead and then get mad at me.
And we don't want that.
Oh.
Uh, save again, my bad.
I am.
Between my bees and my gun, I feel like the pain.
Where are they shooting it?
I don't know what's going on, but we're just going to keep
on going.
Oh, bees?
This is kind of awesome!
Wait, I should be, like, taking photos of them when I
release the bees.
How do I get to the place?
Wait.
Farmer's Market.
Oh yeah, we have to get back to Arcadia.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Return to Arcadia.
Using the lightning makes you Vulcan then?
I guess so.
I'm a one-man army.
Game save.
Oh, this way.
Ah, the Farmer's Market.
Smells like...
Don't fight the inevitable.
Big Daddy, help!
No, why didn't you do anything?
Just running.
I thought he would like...
Oh, you're still here.
Guys, I don't think she likes it.
Anyway.
Get caught by bees!
We gotta be...
for the bees.
Static discharge too.
Is your old static discharge not slowing them down enough?
Upgrade to...
No!
Nice!
Uh...
Oh.
We are taking less damage with the fire.
I'll keep what I have.
We'll keep what I have for now.
Bees!
Yeah, bees!
Wait, there's a...
There's a little sister in here?
I got all these, though, no?
Let me save.
Okay.
I feel like that's too close.
You know?
I feel like that's too close to her.
I'm not sure.
I'm just gonna save and we'll go for it.
Take a photo!
Oh, you guys are so smart.
Whoa!
Photographer's I2!
Thank you.
Okay, uh, what was I gonna do?
Oh, I was gonna save and then I was gonna run past them.
Awesome, we just got photographer's I1.
Lobbies!
Yeah, I do have the one more sister.
This is just the one.
No way!
Wait.
Oh no, that's her.
She got me good.
I didn't expect her to be in here.
My wallet is full.
So Binto has the fury, the pain, and cool bar, cool bar.
Is Big Daddy mind control the fear, the sorrow?
Maybe the fear, because it's like a little juicy.
What was she doing, though?
That is a great question.
What was she doing, you little freakazoid?
Yeah.
Oh, I haven't hacked this yet.
Let's hack it.
I don't like this one, honestly.
this one like uh oh wait wait i haven't been giving anything
that will make it you i was too late oh no let's hack it
again oh oh okay okay okay oh nice nice nice okay the game
is somewhat kind sometimes the game is kind sometimes oh my
gosh sometimes though only sometimes hello wait no no No,
no, no!
I don't want to set off an alarm.
I messed that one up.
That was all me.
Minto.
I know, I had it.
I really did have it.
I dropped the ball.
These ones do stress me out, though, because they're like...
Just don't give me what I need sometimes.
And they're fast.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, what can we make now?
Oh, yeah.
I wish I could tell how many I have.
Anyway, that's fine.
We hacked it.
I'm going to do this part next time!
Next time!
I'm gonna go eat dinner, y'all.
Guys!
This was fun.
Arcadia.
Or what if I do just put it in?
What will happen?
No, we'll wait till next time.
We'll wait till next time.
Thank you guys so much for more Bioshock!
Yuppie!
Thank you for the long stream.
Yeah!
I feel like we maybe made good progress.
I don't know, actually.
Musashi, thank you!
You really should be taking pictures of them.
I believe it gives more... Okay, I'm gonna take... Fine!
a picture right now!
What's up, Darko?
Thank you so much for the pink!
Ha!
Wait, it gives so much more now.
Wait, hmm?
Ha!
Oh, okay.
She doesn't count.
Thanks for more Bioshock, you're doing so well at the game,
so don't sweat any scoff.
Thank you!
Thanks, Dogapine!
Yeah, C is not bad.
See, sees get degrees.
That's just a person.
Well, she's dead.
And that's exciting, no?
Thanks for distributing.
If you get something good for dinner.
I have a bento waiting for me in my fridge.
Yahoo!
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
It's great seeing you getting better at the game in real
time.
I'm having so much fun.
I'm feeling a little less, like, jumpy, spooky about it, you
know?
Good progress today.
Thanks.
Thank you.
What kind of bento?
Karage.
Yummy.
Chicken.
Oh, it's a meantime, everybody.
Oh, no, wait.
No.
I can't let you leave yet.
You guys got to help me pick my thing.
Hold on.
Quit.
I did save, right?
Which is a hilarious thing to ask.
Yeah, I saved.
Quit.
Quit the windows.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
I remembered at the last second hold on Okay, so I found
this I found this place Right Hold on, let me put on some
music I'm so hungry though I'm gonna make this kind of quick
Let me get rid of my tabs Okay
Okay, look how cute this place is No?
Oh, wait, I think I did the wrong one.
Oh, I did the wrong one.
Hold on.
Wait, hold on.
Wait, I did the wrong one.
It's like DIY craft kits.
Okay.
Aren't they so cute?
Look, you can make pillows and you make them.
I'm such a sucker for like making things myself.
Right?
I was like, I kind of want to get this bag.
I can make the bag.
That's so fun.
And then they have rugs.
And I really want to get the rugs for my next maid cafe.
I'm obsessed with this one.
Look, I don't even know if I'll have a mirror like this.
But I'm like, what if I do get a mirror like this?
And then I can put it there.
And look how cute.
And you make it.
You make it yourself.
I mean, it's pretty expensive.
But at the same time, I was thinking of maybe getting me and
Vicky and Fee some like look look this is so cute no and
these ones are not so they're for mugs look look how cute
you can put your mug on there look how cute it's called the
craft club call if you're curious oh look at that how cute
the mushrooms are and so I want you to think look at the
strawberries I know oh they're so cute and I want to get
some for for for for my maid cafe too I really I really like
this one.
And they have different like autumn ones.
The butterfly.
This one's cute too.
Snowdrops.
The lighting bugs.
Wait!
This one is like Vicky's colors, no?
Maybe I get the rose bush for Vicky.
Where's the graveyard one?
And then maybe this like a flower patch one.
Wait.
Oh, they have a bundle!
I wonder if you can pick what you want.
No.
Wait, but these three are cute, though.
Go for it.
You're being so creative.
It would be perfect for you.
Very cute.
This would be perfect for Berrybug.
And then I also want to make a rug.
I want to get a rug that...
Look at how I love the stamp.
They're so stinking cute.
I think it's really funny that they're so expensive and you
have to make it yourself.
But at the same time, I love the novelty of it.
Get the garden friends.
What's the garden friends?
Oh, this one?
Look how cute!
They're like ginormous coasters, which I think is also
pretty funny.
But they're so cute.
The process of making it as part of the attraction.
I know!
I love it!
I love it.
I definitely want this one for myself.
The floral grove.
And maybe the lavender one for myself too.
No, the daisy!
Daisy.
They're so stinking cute.
The sunflower one is also really cute.
I want to get, like, a couple for me.
Oh, and the rug seemed, like, pretty decent size.
Like, hold on.
The one I was looking at.
The mirror one.
This one.
Look at her holding it.
pretty big.
That's a good size a rug.
Right?
I won't let me click on it for some reason, but that's a
good size rug.
Then it comes with everything.
That's huge for you.
That seems like a good size, right?
I probably won't get the pose.
Made cute!
Excited to watch the jazz concert vaude tomorrow!
I keep forgetting about it.
even though I ordered the mod last weekend.
Well, you have lots of time to watch it, but be sure to
watch it before it's gone, gone, gone.
Thank you so much.
How do I say your name?
Splur, splur, splur, splur.
Thank you.
And then also look at the pots.
Sorry.
Look at the whole sweetie pie.
It's so cute.
My favorite mug, I'm actually using it right now, strawberry
and then today i got a strawberry okay so there's this brand
i really love called obake new and i found there it's like
obake is ghost right that's me and then new is like newy
right like obake new but um they had they had a strawberry
obake new plushie and i bought him
I want to make, I want to make, I kind of like have been
itching for like a, you know, kind of how I made the
puppets, right?
I should make some more.
I still have more ingredients.
But, wait, the blossoms?
This one's really cute too for the three of us.
I feel like maybe I should get a bundle so that we can all
get one.
This one's really cute too.
The tulips.
Wait, cottage garden.
Wait, this might be the perfect one because I like all three
and I think they would like all.
Oh, it's sold out.
Dang it.
But I did give Nimmy her hand puppet.
Yeah, I did.
But I've been itching for like a handy craft thing, you
know?
Fuzzy and floral.
That one's...
Wait, this one has...
Oh, this one is so cute!
Okay, I'm going to get this one.
They're on sale, so I'm going to grab it, you know.
And then I'm going to grab a couple more.
You think it's a good idea?
Do you guys think that they would?
like them.
I just kind of want to do like a craft.
Do it?
Yeah?
You think so?
Okay.
Maybe whatever one I choose we can make on stream.
And then I can have a coaster that we made together in my
new maid cafe.
Go get this one.
Yeah!
This one's really cute too.
I like the strawberries so much.
I'm a strawberry girl.
And what rug?
Wait.
Well, go back to rugs.
What rug do you think I should get?
Shit to make.
I like the tulips.
I like the strawberry.
I like the sardine stamps.
I like all the stamp ones.
I think they're pretty cute too.
this one it's cute pink portal where's that one cloudy pink
portal I feel like it looks it's different colors no in
lighting strobe look at that guy these are it's like the
perfect kind of rug for like when you're washing dishes no I
am indecisive this one I really like too with the P&D And
these are the tulips.
Oh, lemons!
I love them all!
These would go perfect next to my foxhound metal gear rugs.
Some of them I'm like, these are like too funky for me.
They're cute, but they're like a little too funky.
Right?
Look, you like draw the whole thing and then you put it all
in.
This one's cute though.
If you have a mirror that goes to the floor.
The thing is, is I don't.
I want this one so much because it's so nice.
This one.
Oh, look at the little frog.
I am my yo.
I am.
I can't not choose.
Looks like pizza.
Oh, I'm hungry.
Oh, a sardine stamp is too cute though.
Can you use the half in front of a doorway?
Oh, that's true.
Maybe a lot.
Yeah.
Aren't they just so cute, though?
They're so pretty.
Maybe the strawberry would be good.
Most loved.
This one's really pretty.
I really like it.
It feels like...
Especially with this girl's heels.
Holy moly.
It feels timeless.
Or a bookshelf or at the base of a bed.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, this is what I'll be doing to make my rug.
Oh, it's like more plush than I thought it would be.
Right?
Like these are long.
Cool.
Oh my gosh, just kind of doing something with my hands.
Cute girly hobby.
Yeah, maybe if I get good, Right?
If I try this and get good, and then maybe one day I could
make one and like one of one and sell it.
Or I could make a couple.
And like, I mean, I blew one!
I could make an I blew one!
It is kind of mesmerizing.
Why is this gift 10 hours long?
Yeah.
Auction it for charity or something.
My sister does stuff like this.
She made me a red Pikmin.
It was cute.
Wait, that's so cute though.
I can't stop watching.
Wait, is she just doing the same one over and over?
Oh, it is a loop!
I really- I'm stupid.
Okay, guys, I gotta go eat.
Thanks for- I- I- well, thanks for having me.
me this help me with with deciding the coasters at least i
was kind of like hmm what to do but i think they will might
like it so let's i'll try and get some we'll get coasters
together we'll have matching den setsu coasters together and
they're very sweet looking yay thank you everybody thank you
oh for real this time have a good day have a good night
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you.
Don't tell them.
Hopefully they come in time.
I'll let you think about it.
But I'll see them again if I don't see it this...
If it doesn't come in this trip.
Osumito!
I'll order it tonight.
Number one.
Break the 32!
Eat the next time!
Bye-bye.